et mes douze lovers les podcasts
aujourd'hui est présenté par jules frais
les jus les plus frais en ville on a un
code promo sur les jus qui sont
excessivement savoureux csf 20 à 20 % de
rabais sur votre commande les juges ont
été pressés point qui fait la veille
livré chez vous le lendemain
s'il est à montréal c'est un coût fixe
de 3 dollars et sinon c'est les frais de
postes canada pour ailleurs au québec
pour les jus les plus frais au monde
yes puis en ce moment par là qu'on vous
parle est un concours sur la page de jus
frais point c est donc encore pour
gagner 50 $ de jus la seule force des
affaires c'est d'inscrire quelques
informations sur le concours et si vous
passer une commande j'avais deux fois
plus de chances de gagner le concours
est valide jusqu'au 28 février à minuit
donc trible w point jus frais points 6e
puis honnêtement si vous tripes et jus
ou même si vous trompez pas julo vous
allez commencer à triper vue parce que
c'est les meilleurs jus que moi j'ai bu
fait que j'espère c'est juste les
meilleurs merci jus frais puis d'homme
quelle est la tagline qu'on a inventé
sens aucune 30 personnes nous le demande
j'ai aussi dans le podcast de cette
semaine et présenté par ffs a eu l'aval
la faculté des sciences de
l'administration de l'université laval à
québec notre université notre vie
mouiller c'est là que nous on est allé
puis on adoré notre expérience du moins
je parle au nom mais je pense que
j'inclus donne là dedans tout à fait
seul laval offre une diversité de
programmes que ce soit des
microprogrammes jusqu'à dr up pour
n'importe qui en fait qui veut soit pas
refaire certaines connaissances pousser
encore plus loin son domaine d'étude
ça fait plus de 25 ans qui offre des
cours en ligne en fait au dessus de 40
programmes en ligne
c'était pas des programmes présentiel
qui ont été transférés en ligne pour la
pandémie laisser des programmes sont
monté spécialement en ligne de façon
interactive donc pour vous garder à
l'affût pour garder ça intéressant y est
donc peut-être que le contexte présent
vous avez plus de temps à faire des
cours en ligne peut-être que vous avez
besoin de changement dans votre carrière
votre et emploie ses besoins de
nouvelles compétences de nouveaux outils
fse eu l'aval est là pour vous il est
même un billet 100% en ligne que vous
que vous pouvez faire si vous venez de
vous partez vous passez à votre compte
ou vous songez vous passez à votre
compte il ya des microprogrammes des
formations spécialisées pour vous pour
que vraiment vous ayez toutes les
compétences nécessaires pour
l'entrepreneuriat hu est allé voir en
fait pour voir tous leurs programmes
dans le lien qu'on va mettre dans la
description du podcast moi je sais que
pour un fait je regarde ça pour essayer
de trouver des meilleurs outils pour
mieux naviguer les eaux troubles de
l'entrepreneuriat ou merci à fait cela
une production du studio sf bio sans
filtre le bois de castres on parle
lorsqu'on veut que nos invités
je fais à chanter avec moi dôme plan que
le vous on reçoit cornet grand plaisir
de recevoir cet article
corneille que marquis notre jeunesse qui
l'on pourrait dire légendaire certains
pourraient dire légendaire début du mois
je me suis acheté jeunes quand j quand
j'entends tu connais mais parfois ça m'a
marqué à jamais un éviter passionnèrent
moi c'est une me paquette préféré qu'on
a fait ici un gars super brillant super
intelligent si particulier qui a
vraiment quelque chose à dire qu'il ya
eu une vie vraiment
très particulière et on a parlé de pain
enfants de parler d'indépendance du
québec on a parlé des réseaux sociaux
on a parlé de pourparlers en ph
mais on a parlé de l'importance d'avoir
des dialogues dans société
parce que quand et qui trouvent que de
plus en plus en fait dans ce canton dans
des positions se fait mettre dans des
petites boîtes c'est difficile d'avoir
un discours nuancé je pense quelque
chose qu'ils l'occupent particulièrement
qui nous occupe nous aussi
particulièrement donc c'était un plaisir
d'y parler écouter
si vous aussi vous voulez nous entendre
parler davantage la conversation sur
corner on à l'est encore moins de
filtres qu'on enregistre deux mois et
nicole qui sont après tout les podcasts
et qui sont exclusifs au monde pétri ont
donc ciblé
si vous voulez nous entende parler
davantage allez vous inscrire vous
inscrire par don sur notre page et tuant
les infos loin dans la description du
podcast et like et quand tu participes
addition vous connaissez le cha
lalalalalala carboneco dias rouillé
[Musique]
merci beaucoup d'être là avec nous c'est
un réel plaisir ça me fait plaisir plein
d'affaires qu'on veut aborder avec toi
que je sais même pas par où commencer
comment si ton podcast badauds et
félicitations merci versa comme je
disais avant là j'essaie de de suivre ou
pas les originaux par castres c'est que
sa forme à qui je trouve tellement à le
faire la caisse qui était derrière
l'idée de vouloir lancer ce d'avoir
déduction parce qu'on sentait nous ont
fait à peu près une heure quarante-cinq
ans moyens mais tout ça c'est de passer
qu'est-ce qui est venu beaucoup de
frustration à la base je fais un métier
qui est très je ne sais pas trop mais
éternisé là-dessus on pourrait faire une
thèse là dessus mais chez un métier qui
est très trompeur c'est un métier que tu
commence en disant c'est le fun de
pouvoir m'exprimer
puis quand ça se passe bien comme dans
mon cas bâton expression et trouve
clients puis retrouve un public puis sa
vie paisible c'est ça ma vie d'artiste
et ça y'a pas plus rêver que ça comme
vie tu t'exprimes au new york times
comme on dit en bon français c'est pas
le cas de tout le monde dans mon cas moi
ça c'est comme ça que ça s'est passé
puis tu en vie puis on avait super bien
en plus puis tu as l'illusion que ça va
continuer à être ça
clairement donné tu te rends compte que
finalement c'est une prophétie une
profession c'est un métier c'était plus
ta petite guitare dans un coin à écrire
des chansons puis un a crié ttt
tourments puis à les exorciser c'est
plus c'est un métier puis avec tous les
métiers
ça vient avec un des penchants mais ça
vient avec des penchants négatifs mais
je pense que c'est parce que oui c'est
bien que tu ya pire comme métier on
s'entend mais c'est le choc entre la
tente et la réalité qui est tellement
brutale puis une des frustrations que
j'avais justement c'est de sentir à quel
point quand tu es artiste
tu es dans une boîte puis ça se fait
tout seul c'est ça 18 à des artistes qui
se plaignent visage tanné dans une boîte
oui il ya une parc mais c'est vous
parlez d'un terme très populaire c'est
systémique
c'est dans la chair du système les
boîtes sont dans le système dans le
système
tu commences pis y'a comme ya plein de
joueurs il ya plein d'éléments de
facteurs qui se mettent ensemble le
public les médias qui te serve de
vitrine toi même tes ambitions pita
psychologie puis tout ça se met ensemble
finalement se trouve dans une boîte sais
même plus comment une ces boîtes là
c'est ses comptes artistes et charpennes
5 par exemple est-ce qu'on s'entend
quand un artiste qui monte sur l'artiste
engagé politiquement mais artiste
populaire
le but dans la vie c'est de cette plaire
au plus grand monde en tout cas c'est ce
que ce que tu pense donc avoir une
position où des positions tranchées sur
n'importe quel sujet encore plus
aujourd'hui avec les médias sociaux
j'arrive c'est délicat
et si tu as envie de défendre une
position la moelle des chaussées d'avoir
du temps ouais tu peux pas le faire une
chanson c'est ça un couplet un refrain à
coupler pire peut-être un bridge mais
c'est trois minutes trente sites pendant
d'accord dans la nuance avec tout le
génie du monde n'a pas le temps de le
faire dans l'union c'est pour ça qu'ils
aient beaucoup de poésie beaucoup du
match sèchement c'est une façon lâche de
cocon à nos auteurs compositeurs de dire
je dis quelque chose
démerdez vous avec j'étais pas obligé
terminé l'atakor voulu et moi j'ai ma
position mais je vous la donne pas assez
mais et là j'ai 2000 wes a commencé en
2010 2011
cette grande frustration d'aller faire
des plateaux télé d'aller dans radio
puis dira-t-elle sujets d'actualité qui
m'intéressent j'ai le goût d'en parler
j'ai écrit une chanson qui parle
indirectement de ça j'ai le goût d'en
parler puis d'être conscient que les 30
secondes qui m'était donné tout ce que
j'allais pouvoir en faire ses membres
hui
comme j'avais juste up essayer de faire
un résumé de quelque chose qui peut pas
se résumer puis dire n'importe quoi
puis cette frustration ses frustrations
sera cumulé un cumul accumulé puis en
2016 je peux bien un livre qu'une
autobiographie puis mais l'écriture de
ce livre la macom ouvert les yeux vers
un autre monde qui est venu de
l'expression sans trop de contraintes
sans restriction dans le temps puis
après j'ai découvert le podcast commence
à écouter des podcasts toutes sortes de
choses
puis je me suis dit j'aime tellement
qu'on se met ça peut-être que je
voudrais en faire aussi billet je suis
allé les deux moyens d'expression que
c'est une amie comment les gens allaient
du meilleur méthode de exprimer des
idées dans toutes leurs nuances et
l'écriture ou le port casque parce que
tu es motivé je t'avais déjà entendu en
entrevue à gauche à droite ça veut dire
je savais que tu es 1 go et le cas
j'avais été très intelligent vous n'avez
aucune idée à quel point tu étais un
intellectuel pertinent le dit quand tu
t'exprimes et dieu merci j'ai écouté des
podcasts et puis c'est vraiment vraiment
excellente idée des grandes discussions
ce pas important de savoir si tu vois je
pense qu'il sert et les médiums qui
permet sa piste un médium ou sait qui
est qui et qui vivent très pipi près de
là la vraie vie kipré de ski ce que doit
être un humain juste de s'asseoir puis
de discuter tandis que met-on t par
exemple ici on va parler d'idées on va
débattre de pignons mais jamais je fais
sur ces réseaux sociaux parce que pour
moi c'est le une perte totale de temps
et d'énergie ne sais pas ce qu'il y'a
rien tout à fait raison pour moi y'a
rien là dessus qui ressort de bonté
parce que justement les idées peuvent
s'exprimer avec nuance
les gens sont automatiquement dans la
confrontation temps expliquant qu'on
s'assoit face à face on vend beaucoup
plus essayer de trouver un terrain
d'entente puis trouver aussi mais se
trouvait ou plutôt où est-ce qu'on sa
coque tout parce qu'il est différente
mais
que tu as tellement raison et le pire de
la chose c'est que les réseaux sur les
réseaux sociaux qui sont rendus nôtre
c'est un monde c'est un vrai univers
dans lequel nous vivons nous en tout cas
on a l'impression que nous pensons pas
resserré par ces réseaux là nous
trouvons l'information dans ses réseaux
là nous exprimons qui nous sommes sûrs
par instagram part nous sommes ça nous
sommes devenus saints c'est quand même
ce que magna n'était pas la laine mais
il est presque aussi important que
maintenant presque aussi importante est
ce qui est flippant à ce qui est
vraiment peur c'est quand tu penses que
le set polar cette polarisation
justement qui est inhérente aux hauts
médiums et les quasi vous voulu au
départ
ouais je pense que vous avez vu il ya
des matins à manquer la wii a lu des
documents tout ce n'est pas vu encore ce
netflix mais c'est plus le latin c'est
ça la thèse que l'algorithme les réseaux
sociaux en fait lors de leur nature
favorise soupe parce que c'est payant
pour renforcer la rotation des bols et
un peu seul
le constat du de classe et jouer sur les
passions facile de l'être humain
parce que c'est ça le jeu peut pas
cracher sur le capitalisme le modèle
capitaliste et ça c'est productivité
rentabilité ce qui veut dire que si tu
peux le faire dans un temps record c'est
encore mieux tu passes du temps à faire
de l'argent
mieux c'est pour en faire plus dans un
grand une journée était plus les réseaux
sociaux c'est un petit peu ça mais ce
qui fait peur c'est abandonner un
j'oublie son nom j'avais vu une sortie
d'un
ding a ajout plus un gars brillant là
j'oublie ce nom je vais jouer le google
goog les jeux vous donner son nom ça
un canadien un ingénieur électricien je
pense à la base qui finalement s'est
retrouvé italienne à l'université d'ohio
lupi ontario pis après le décidément sa
famille vient du sri lanka
il a décidé de de se mettre dans la tête
qui s'est fait engager par un ol je
pense quelque chose comme ça puis il a
fini chez facebook dont il est un des
indes et fondateur de facebook qu'elle a
fait une sortie faisait beaucoup de
conférences dans les grandes écoles dans
les villes x course aux états unis p
abandonné avec comme une espèce de
pétage de plomb où il a comme vendu la
mèche la mèche où il dit que moi j'étais
là à la conception de toutes ces
affaires là puis on le savait que ça
allait aller parce que tu peux pas ne
pas le savoir
je pense sincèrement que on peut pas
s'étonner des on peut pas s'étonner des
conséquences négatives des technologies
parce qu'on sait que c'est des êtres
humains qui sont à la base puis on est
on est tellement notre psychologie à
tous est tellement fragile
tu as beau être le plus grand génie du
monde tu peux pas inventer quelque chose
de sain à 100% parce que les raisons
pour lesquelles tu le cresson forcément
pas juste scène par la nature par la
lettre par ta nature humaine c'est juste
que tu as tellement de je pense que ces
gens il voulait tellement changer le
monde c'est prêt c'est il ya beaucoup
d'ego là dedans quand tu veux changer le
monde il voulait tellement changé le
monde qu'ils ont fait à n'importe quel
prix puis le prix en train de le payer
maintenant je sais il n'y a rien rien je
veux pas dire qu'il ya rien de bon dans
les réseaux sociaux mais a beaucoup de
mal à ça c'est un phénomène qui est
somme toute assez récent parce que ben
en fait les réseaux sociaux en général
dans l'échelle du monde sont extrêmement
récent mais plus si on approche un peu
plus du présent le début des réseaux
sociaux n'était pas comme ça tu mets ton
je pense à instagram qui est m
plateforme pour les photographes les
artistes pour pour promouvoir pour
montrer leur heure pour faire du beau
tipi rapidement ça le prix une autre
tangente lorsque j'imagine la masse
c'est l'état propriétaire
c'est là que le problème est né lorsque
lorsque on a réalisé que finalement on
pourrait répondre aux besoins de la
nature humaine qui était d'être en
conflit constant dessus puis sur les
réseaux sociaux en ce moment surtout
dans la dernière année nous on en parle
souvent les réseaux sociaux s'est rendue
une source de négatif de 1,6 conflit
plus grande que le bal en positif qui
fait qu s'est rendu à un point où est ce
qu'on se dit à qui a avant les réseaux
sociaux nous permettait de nous
rapprocher tout le monde ensemble me
permettait de suivre ma mère sur
internet me permettait de connecter avec
tous ces gens le puits là j'en suis à me
dire je vais juste les enlever parce que
c'est c'est trop nocifs
c'est trop nocif pour parce que chat
manquons flec des gens que tu serais pas
en conflit dans la vie c'est parce que
ça fait jusqu'à présenter le 3 % des
choses qui étaient en désaccord avec les
gens mais que les 97 % avec lequel
dépend d'accord on l'abordé jamais ça
fait je segmenté encore plus là les
pensées puis ça tu ça tue le dialogue
puis pour revenir à l'idée du podcast
nous initialement c'était solide et de
cp l'idée de partir le studio ici à ce
que les gens peuvent venir louer pour
avoir des conversations pour faire des
dépôts de gaz de forme longue
c'était précisément ça c'est essayer de
ramener le dialogue dans société mais ce
qu'on a vu dans la dernière année ou du
moins depuis qu'on a parti le studio
c'est un corps plus dans le pose et il
ya encore moins de dialogues qui se fait
et encore plus d'opposition pires aux
visées de rennes qui partager dans la
dernière année c'est ça le salaire
augmente et probablement la pandémie
sont en jouer là dedans dans l'est
l'humeur des gens dans la façon que les
gens de se se sentent impuissants face
est une situation fait qu'ils ont aussi
de se réapproprier une certaine un
certain contrôle de l'or de l'or
narrative mais métier même car si ce cas
qu'on a lancé le studio s'est déjà dans
cette optique là
c'est devenu encore priori on se dit
c'est quoi là c'est quoi la solution
comment qu'on sort de cette ce manque
complet de discussion seulement complet
nuance comment qu'on réussit à sortir de
ce type parce que l'oeil et était
d'arrêter soit dans un camp puis rue tu
parlé un petit peu de la boîte ans dans
le domaine musical c'est ça maintenant
tu es déçoit de gauche t soit de droite
t soit blanc classement du ft soit en
live matin et soir les artistes en
musique en tout cas on pas le droit
d'être à droite
non maintenant ça fait la force qui est
complètement absurde parce que ça
premièrement je trouve ça ça c'est une
c'est une saisie des informations c'est
une manque d'éducation intolérable en
politique parce que tu es en train
d'expliquer aux gens que quand un
créateur
tu ne peux qu'adhérer aux idées de
gauche c'est quelque chose qui se ça se
sent très très vite écoute tabou t'as
pas besoin d'être politisé tu as besoin
de quelqu'un qui s'intéresse à la
politique pour que dès que tu commences
à avoir du succès en musique
tu te rends compte que c'est là que tu
te ranges biologiquement ce qui est
poche parce que vraiment gauche droite
qu'est ce que ça veut dire tu es à
autant de gauche qui a deux je sais plus
ce que ça veut dire la gauche bastos
assouplies et entendre amplifier un
débat qui est qui qui est beaucoup plus
complexe combiné aux infections
exactement exactement mais en les
dictant en étiquetant les choses comme
ça bah ça s'empêche les artistes quand
tu penses le la vraie valeur d'un
artiste en tout cas on voudrait que ce
soit son auteur sur l'authenticité soit
qui tu es réellement
et c'est là que tu trouves tu as valeur
parce que les artistes on veut qu'ils
sont un petit peu ce qu'ils expriment
avec poésie
qui transforme le le malheur la douleur
quelque chose de beau pour rendre la vie
plus tolérable on le fait pour soi en
puis finalement ça finit malgré nous de
servir aux autres également dans le même
sens mais quand tu penses que certains
sujets sur lequel tu peux pas m'exprimer
parce que ce que tu en penses est pas
populaire ça brime tellement que on voit
beaucoup de gens qui se présentent en
télé petite impression qui n'ont plus
rien à dire mais ils ont plus rien à
dire parce qu'ils n'osent pas dire ce
qu'ils pensent réellement c'est pour ça
que c'est quand tu dors que tu parlais
de mode c'est un beau compliment le pire
si tu avais le nom de gens que je
connais d'artistes brillantissime avec
des aspirations et des curiosités
intellectuelle que tu pourrais même pas
imaginer mais qui ont l'air tellement
plate en télé qui ont l'air tellement
dada comme on dit en en télé parce
qu'ils disent non moi je pas envie de
risquer mon capital de sympathie
c'est comme goût greenpeace aucune idée
de ce que ça veut dire vraiment
d'éléments pandémie puis était parti là
dessus parce que c'est ça yahia c'est
dicté tout nous est dictée puis je
déplore ça parce que si même les
artistes ont plus le droit d'exprimer
qu'ils sont i où j'ai une amie artiste
chanteuse tai chi qui me disait en
confession dans le privé de ses mots
j'écoute le podcast de mathieu bock côté
je sais que tu leur soit en passant plus
de lits 13,0 me dis moi j'écoute ont pas
de carte secret
c'est à méditer pied à bleuets sentait
qu'ils étaient comme à maladie mais elle
avait peur de médiation rampe réaction à
ces questions est ce qu'elle est blanche
ou même une pile après ce que j'ai dit
c'est qu'avec toi le droit d'écouter le
picasso matisse braque à fait acquis
parce qu'il ya déjà que je pourrais pas
dire ce que je pourrai jamais je
partagerai jamais un podcast mettons
qu'il tient pas qu'à ce match côté je
trouve bon tout près c'est de partager
mes amis je mettrai jamais se construit
sur instagram ce podcast lui parce que
je vais me faire ramos ici quand même
inquiétant quand on pense à ce titre et
sacré une telle hégémonie la pensée sur
instagram qu'on a même présent qui était
quand même pas le droit d'exprimer une
idée qui est un petit peu et dissidentes
à l'espèce du courant de pensée
majoritaire seppi [ __ ] c'est toute la
france et le
je pense que dans la formulation le
courant de pensée majoritaire
je pense que c'est pas majoritaire je
pense que c'est l'époque courant de
pensée le plus brillant sur instagram
ouais c'est ça
parce que quand tu penses à ce est
beaucoup plus de personnes qui expose
pas leur opinion que de gens qui qui qui
prône le courant de pensée le plus
bruyante et je pense que c'est la
majorité
je pense que si on en parle souvent je
pense c'est la minorité bruyante qui
dicte la bonne pensée avoir saoulé sur
les réseaux sociaux qui nous rend
inconfortable à dire quelque chose de
différent par rapport à ce courant le
tout doit être raison mais c'est
d'autant plus inquiétant parce que te
dis mais la majorité est moins bon il
est où piqué psychologiquement qu'est ce
qui se passe quand la majorité en train
de build up toutes ces petites
frustrations de je peux pas m'exprimer
je pouvais m'exprimer je peux exprimer
j'ai peur de ce qui arrive quand on
arrive à saturation
une majorité qui ne s'exprime pas même
pas besoin d'être une majorité proches
d'une majorité 48% sa hélitreuille c'est
ça qui se passe
j'ai pas envie de vue dans un pays comme
ça d'autant plus que la côte pas comment
est ce que tu viens de me dire la samhsa
ça me peine tellement de savoir qu'on
doit se cacher pour écouter le podcast
métier c'est mathieu bock-côté c'est un
intellectuel avec des aspirations
idéologique nationalistes souverainistes
pis tu peux être en désaccord avec
plusieurs points qui à la fin c'est
qu'ils ont lieu de la mesure est d
accord je pense et puis c'est comme si
le seul fait d'exprimer c'est lui
justement bonté clairement t il est pro
multiculturalisme anti multiculturalisme
traits plutôt genre de gars qui
proposerait une diminution des seuils
d'immigration par exemple tout une
augmentation si c'est oui j'en doute et
le protégé de paul étaient partis
politiques le pardon qui rapidement ça
colle une étiquette de raciste et
xénophobe temps que ses potes il ya il
ya une juste terminée tout c'est comme
si le seul fait c'est le fait d'exprimer
une idée qui va à l'encontre des valeurs
de d'inclusion pied d'égalité
c'est comme si rapidement on disait ça
c'est une pente glissante vers le
fascisme si c'est comme si rapidement le
fait de positionner un petit peu plus à
droite
rapidement le c'était c'est que c'était
white précis vraiment rapidement c'est
un disque et c'est pas aussi non mais
c'est pas ça du tout mais comme souvent
chez ces noms mais je sais je sais dans
la tete de bandit monde c'est des idées
qui sont ultra dangereuse parce qu'ils
vont nous amener il vraiment à des
horreurs parce qu'il ya eu des erreurs
dans pas d'en passer ce qui skie
vraiment une exagération sans nom très
grande exagération
il a tellement de choses dans ce que tu
viens de dire
prenez moi je trouve qu'il est aussi
fâché sinon plus fasciste d'interdire la
parole de quelqu'un dont on présume le
racisme le fascisme que d'être fasciste
soi même c'est à dire que de terre une
partie de la population ces novices
aussi un vrai une vraie tendance d'un
régime fasciste bas absolument donc à un
moment donné quand une certaine parole
et rendu interdite
on va prendre l'exemple de mathieu
bock-côté c'est ça qui est plate aussi
là c'est que on est souvent mis en
position de défendre un individu une
personnalité qu'on n'a pas
nécessairement vraiment qui a pas besoin
de défense pour qu'ils annoncent qu'ils
aient besoin de défense
les copies connais pas ça naît ça m'a
d'accord les culés on n'est pas
nécessairement d'accord avec lui puis
c'était mon but de ce pack par cast avec
lui deux de discuter à quelqu'un avec
qui j'ai beaucoup de certains désaccords
mais en toute courtoisie en tout en tout
respect mais on est souvent en
opposition on doit défendre quelqu'un
avec qui on n'est pas d'accord parce
qu'on veut défendre le principe de
pouvoir ne pas être d'accord et se
parler quand même mais ses skis et ski
ski et le cool avec ce que vous faites
c'est que vous êtes vous êtes plus jeune
que moi et moi j'ai toujours tous mes
espoirs en votre génération et aux plus
jeunes aussi parce que non parce que
nous a laissé me gêne c'est quoi on
essaie migennes nous latins alors vous
êtes vous êtes jeune mais j'ose espérer
que vous êtes le début de quelque chose
parce que cette notion du dialogue et
est primordial si on veut continuer à
avancer parce que dans le fond on
pourrait se dire c'est quoi on continue
chacun notre petite vie puis c'est la
souffrance est inhérente à la nature
humaine
buzz comme on va regarder mais la
musique est absurbe la vie étape ski
puisque est pas faux ce qui est parfois
mais j'ai je suis pas j'aime beaucoup
choqué nord mais je me fait flipper un
petit peu j'ai quand même un petit brin
d'optimisme mois puis j'aime pas
souffrir
j'aime pas souffrir jeu tant que je peux
j'essaie de l'éviter personnel se ferait
presque oui oui oui
non tout à fait j'aime pas ça
j'essaie de trouver des moyens de
souffrir - puis une des choses qui me
font souffrir
c'est le fait que être une personne
noire aujourd'hui rendu compliqué non
pas seulement parce que on doit
expliquer pourquoi on pense que le
racisme est systémique par exemple à des
gens qui le qui ne croient pas qu'ils ne
voient pas ne veut pas l'accepter c'est
une star du bacon qui peut être
intellectualiser puis si on a la
patience puissions on est de bonne
volonté on peut arriver à se parler mais
aussi parce que encore une fois on est
mis dans des boîtes
on est mis dans des boîtes et comme les
artistes
des fois quand tu es tu es noir tu as
l'impression qu'il faut que tu tiennes
un certain discours et que dénoncer
l'injustice vient forcément avec un
manque de nuance
parce que dénoncer une certaine
injustice est numéro 1 est tout ce qu'il
ya autour en dessous n'existe pas donc
si on a parlé de mathieu bock-côté si un
jour il dit il faudrait réduire le
nombre d'immigrants qui arrivent au
canada et comment un point et que moi
j'arrive d'erreurs que jeudi battue
c'est pas con comme idée on va pas
comprendre
non on va comprendre parce que - comme
personne noire ou comme artiste
sensible et raisonnable et est ouvert
sur le monde
je peux pas avoir ce genre de pensée là
mais c'est parce qu'on va pas laisser
finir plomb n'a pas laissé lui je vais
pas laisser lui finir au site
le on l'a mis en amont à moins d'un ami
à date sur ce que sur ce qu'il a dit on
a rangé quelque part est-ce que ça fait
souvent j'ai vu j'ai vu une différence
entre mathieu bock-côté pendant mon bar
caste et certains de ses tweets
mais oui absolument c'est parce qu'il ya
un confort et un confort à à rester avec
sa gang un gendarme des copies à travers
tout eh oui oui pis c'est humain c'est
humain mais je pense qu'il ya quand même
toujours au fond de chacun nous un réel
besoin d'aller vers celui qui n'est pas
comme nous je pense que c'est c'est
profondément ça c'est ce que je pense
comme rousseau là-dessus là c'est partir
de soi pour aller vers l'universel j'y
crois sincèrement moi j'ai pendant
pendant le mouvement blm tout l'été la
gt gt pas bien pire
on fait quoi tout ça on fait quoi
s'appuient en train de s'en porter ici
et puis qu'est ce qui se passe piquée
quels rapports que j'ai avec man et gris
témoin me le fait d'être noir pire c'est
un autre pas de casse mais quand même si
ça me fait souffrir je n'ai pas le goût
comme qu'est ce que qu'est-ce que je
fais qui ne ce qu'ils soient pas convenu
qu'ils soient pas comme je postais un
écran noir
puis je me suis dit faut être conséquent
si on veut réellement vivre ensemble
l'intérêt est pas dans le fait de parler
quelqu'un qui pense comme nous c'est pas
que ça serve à rien mais je vous vois
pas l'intérêt supplémentaire
l'intéressent aller parler à quelqu'un
qui ne pense pas du tout comme nous et
qui est convaincu de ses opinions et qui
est convaincu de ses positions et
essayer de voir si on peut avoir un
terrain d'entente et ses doigts si on
peut se parler et si franchir ce pas
pose problème
la première c'est une bonne chose ça
veut dire qu'on a touché un touché à un
problème mais ça veut aussi dire que
c'est peut-être ça qu'il faut régler
c'est peut-être ça qu'il faut régler moi
je vois beaucoup de militants gauche
droite anti multiculturaliste
multiculturalisme pro multiculturalisme
anttila ici laïcité pro-laïcité anticipe
rossa je me dis vous manquez vous manqué
la game au compris au complet c'est
c'est en vous parlant que vous allez
trouver une certaine comme ça vous allez
que vous allez arriver à votre but en
fait si si si le but est d'être bien
c'est parce qu'un contenu que que ça va
avancer des biens et des biens ensemble
parce qu'on veut si on vivre ensemble
qui fonctionne le tipi ici c'est très
contradictoire de dire au nom du vivre
ensemble vivre ensemble
ton idée il pas il te parle pas
exactement
j'ai jamais compris ça j'ai jamais
compris ce qu'est ce qui est délicat là
dedans c'est que aisée ce qui complique
le sait ce qui complique est cette
démarche la démarche de dire cela
conséquent si on prône le vivent
ensemble faudra aller parler à ceux qui
ne sont pas comme nous ce qu'ils pensent
pas comme nous ok le problème c'est que
si dans la discussion
on a l'impression que en se situe parce
qu'on est noirs parce qu'on est arabe
parce qu'on est musulman parce qu'on est
gay parce que parce qu'on est une femme
parce qu'on est trans parce qu'on
appartient à un groupe qui qui porte une
certaine injustice en elle une certaine
pas une gêne pas une injustice universel
mais une injustice socialement
spécifiques
on a des fois de la misère à donner ce
privilège supplémentaire à l'autre qu'on
estime être en avantage de pouvoir
s'exprimer et défendre sa cause de même
titre que toi
parce que quelque part c'est moi qui
subit le plus d'injustice donc c'est un
mois d'avoir la plateforme
c'est un mois d'expliquer pourquoi je
souffre autant que je souffre et
pourquoi il faut faire quelque chose ce
qui est la pire chose à faire pour
entamer un dialogue parce que la
personne qu'on imagine être là ce sont
pas nécessairement là elles se sont pas
nécessairement c'est pour ça que le tout
la notion du white preuve d'âge
elle est vraiment complexe à a déballé
parce que je peux pas engager 1 1
un dialogue - corneille personnalités
publiques un noir privilégié je peux pas
engager un dialogue de vivre ensemble en
parlant du white plus volages
au départ je commence mal la faire parce
que la plupart des gens qui viennent
voir en spectacle
j'ai pas l'impression qu'ils sont plus
privilégiés que moi qu'ils sont blancs
c'est moi je suis un match noir mais je
suis un individu avec des spécifiques
spécificités sociales bien à moi qui ne
me permettent pas de dire de partir du
moins du même point de départ que
n'importe quelle personne noire je peux
pas le nom de tous les noirs et pourtant
je défends mon but c'est que y est plus
de diversité à la télé par exemple qui
est plus de diversité à la radio qui est
plus qu on ait plus de noirs dans dans
la fiction québécoise plus de noirs la
radio québécoise mais je ne peux pas
parler au nom de toute une population
dont je partir de mon point de vue et
mon point de vue ne me permet pas de
commencer le dialogue du vivre ensemble
est une revue revendication d'une
certaine équité en parlant du white
pleurer je pars pas bien je dois partir
d'ailleurs puis peut-être qu'on peut y
arriver mais c'est pas mon ma vie ne me
permet pas de commencer comme ça
les deux choses que tu amènes là c'est
deux choses qui sont complètement
différentes mais qui
qui sont indissociables dans l'idée dans
les idéaux politiques par exemple peut
pas parler du why privilège du bloc
monolithique de l'homme blanc blanc
légier alors que l'expérience humaine
est extrêmement polluant c'est que se
tient en termes de d'où tu viens qu'elle
est réellement compris le losc sait
qu'elle est tous appuyé inversement
comme toi tu dis qu'il ya des gens qui
viennent te voir dans la salle tu as
l'impression des plus privilégiés que
probablement beaucoup d'entre eux deux
qui est sans doute le côté puis rien à
voir avec nous tu viens peep-toe fait
que ça c'est une enfant il autre chose
de d'amener de prôner plus de diversité
de vouloir plus de dire si la télé à la
radio c'est un autre enjeu en tant que
terre utile que les deux sont son
collier nécessairement du port une
opinion sur un pli une opinion
différente sur le climat faut juste
normalisée c'est ça exactement faut
normaliser être capable d'avoir une
opinion sur plusieurs artères ou pis
pour revenir à ce que tu dit tout à
l'heure par rapport aux points à la fin
de la phrase telle espèce de culture de
twin de tri je veux pas l'explication
j'aurais juste prendre un exemple
concret lors de la vague de
dénonciations sur les réseaux sociaux
qui a eu lieu au début de la de la
pandémie
admettons - 1 et 2
nous appuyons que j'avais que j'ai pas
vraiment verbalisées sur la place
publique c'était je pense qu'on en a
parlé avec dans un podcast et les listes
anonyme de 2000 non ce n'est pas la
façon de faire ça si c'était mon opinion
sauf que admettons quand on prend la
formule tweet peas et les listes anonyme
ce n'est pas la façon points
mais là je me pose complètement au
mouvement des associations alors que
c'est pas le cas du tout ouais c'est pas
mon opinion s'arrête pas à cela tient on
peut pas fonctionner ouais mais c'est le
problème des réseaux c'est encore une
fois c'est que on est on est forcément
on est forcément poussé dans dans des
tranchées de comment avoir le plus
d'attention
et comment comment susciter le plus de
d'attention puis on dirait que la
formule est trouvé on dirait qu'on a
trouvé la formule de l'attention avec
ses réseaux sociaux et ça ça permet pas
certains certains et certains échanges
s'avère une virgule à certaines virgule
à la place d'un point et c'est très
difficile à défaire ses traits parce que
pendant que toi tu te dis mais pas ce
que je voulais dire c'est beaucoup plus
nuancée que ça citons seul outil pour
t'expliquer et le mérite
c'est pour ça que le lepad cas c est si
important est si important parce que je
les ai vus même avec c'est très
intéressant parce que mon podcast avec
avec avec mathieu ses efforts le plus
écouté de loin mais ce que je trouve
intéressant c'est que même des gens qui
sont allés à des conclusions un peu
hâtives se font reprendre par d'autres
qui disent non non non tu étais pas allé
au bout de ce qu'il a voulu dire t'es
pas là et et ça c'est impossible sur les
réseaux mais c'est possible dans dans ce
format là on a besoin plus que jamais de
comme tu disais normaliser la nuance
c'est hyper important puis c'est ça le
fait de pouvoir dire c'est possible de
penser deux choses qui semblent
contradictoires mais si vous me laissez
le temps de m'expliquer ça fera du sens
et de créer des des endroits des lieux
des plates formes d'aidé des médias qui
permettent ça c'est super important
c'est pour ça que je le vois la mort de
la télé traditionnelle jeux comme wii
merci parce qu'on retrouve pas son autre
chose l'accepter mais oui c'est vrai
qu'à j'ai vu la recommandation de ton
podcast sur mon youtube j'y croyais pas
mes yeux ne s'inscrit que j'ai accès une
conversation de 3h15 encore neil mathieu
bock-côté que ça ça existe
c'est quoi je me suis fait tellement
dire ça mais honnêtement je pensais que
ça allait peut-être là pas polarisé un
petit peu mais qui voyait en fait je
pense c'est ça je pensais qu il avoir un
backlash puis a pas eu tant backlash que
ça mais ça a suscité énormément
d'intérêt
mais moi pendant que je le faisais je
n'avais pas l'impression des dents de
dallas dans la conduite de faire quelque
chose d'absolument et parole dans la
dissidence le zoophile
je parle à un gars que j'estime moi je
parlais aux sociologues aux 6 1
ouais moi je voulais parler à quelqu'un
qui en sociologue quelqu'un qui
s'intéresse vraiment à la politique qui
a oui des idées très tranchées sur sur
le multiculturalisme la laïcité tout ça
mais un sociologue qui quand il dit des
choses peuvent être backé par une
certaine connaissance et aussi parce que
j'étais intrigué par le cerveau d'un
nationaliste intellectuelle ça c'est
quelque chose qui me kim qui me fascine
est ce que je trouve très intéressant
c'est un petit peu comme ce qu'on disait
sur sur la technologie la psychologie
humaine était la fondation de tous et
puis j'ai toujours trouvé qu'il y avait
une contradiction aux cochons arrivé au
québec en 97
je parlais a plein d'amis haïtiens qui
puis le peu qu'on parlait de politique
parce que j'ai toujours toujours été je
me suis toujours intéressé à la
politique
on me disait parisot parisot c'est un
raciste ce cas pourquoi il a dit cette
phrase horrible il a dit si nous avons
perdu c'est à cause du vote ethnique
je te comme ok mais c'était vrai nom
oui mais comme c'est vrai il a sûrement
perdu parce que il a pas su aller
chercher ce monde et je me suis dit
depuis façon factuelle
ouais c'est ça mais ça m'a déjà je suis
un petit peu naïf des fois mais oui
c'est vrai mais c'était une façon de
condamner ce qui était à la base de sa
défaite
j'aime ok admettons et depuis j'ai
jamais compris pourquoi le pq n'a jamais
sauté sur l'occasion pour réparer sa
faute même si stratégiquement moi si
j'avais tué avait perdu à cause du vote
ethnique
c'est celui-là que j'aurais été chercher
j'ai l'impression qu'ils pensent que
c'est tellement une cause perdue comme
la peine de mettre des affaires là
dedans ce qui ce qui est la pire
attitude avoir parce que si ici une
seule manière de faire la dépendance
aujourd'hui c'est d'inclure toutes les
crises arc de l'homme se soit jamais
possible cepalc exactement et c'est pour
ça que mathieu m'intéressait et
m'intéresse toujours parce que je
voulais savoir ce qui est ce qui importe
le plus un souverainiste qui lui vouent
de même expliqué qu'il coûte fait partie
de ce mouvement depuis l'âge de 15 ans
et dans sa chair puis un certain point
il dit prêt ce qui qui qui se
sacrifierait pour la cause l'est moins
quelqu'un peut croire une dissymétrie
elle irait au bûcher pour cet anneau
m'écoute je crois parce qu'à remonter le
temps dans le pack cash
moi j'essaie de lui faire comprendre que
je je ne pense pas que je pense que la
politique ses grandes idées politiques
et les les appartenances qu'on nous vend
à chacun ne ne servent que ne servent
que d' excuses de prétexte pour ne pas
passer trop de temps à ce qui nous
préoccupe réellement parce que c'est
trop souffrant mais je disais je pense
pas que le
les québécois vont se coucher le soir en
pensant alors qu aux souverainistes ou
pas ou à l'immigration ou qui pensent à
leurs enfants à leurs conjoints qui est
peut-être malade a alors à leur façon
d'arrondir les fins de mois alors des
choses très très terre-à-terre c'est ce
qui nous gardaient veille la nuit et
c'est ce qui nous reste c'est ce à quoi
on pense le matin je pense pas qu'on se
lève le matin en se disant le voile mais
c'est le religieux mais je me suis rendu
compte que lui oui lui oui et c'est ça
qui est fascinant c'est que il est
habité jusque dans la chair par ces
questions là et moi dans une certaine
mesure aussi parce que des fois je vais
me coucher et je pense à ces choses là
et donc je me suis dit c'est quoi c'est
quoi la psychologie derrière ça et je me
pose ces questions là depuis depuis que
j'ai commencé à chialer parce qu'ils
avaient pas assez de noir l'atelier
passé de 6 passes je suis toujours à la
recherche d'une solution
encore une fois souffrir moins souffrir
- hey hey hey hey hey hey mama
conversion avec mathieu m'a confirmé ce
que je soupçonnais c'est qu'il ya une
profonde blessure
ces chats chez certains québécois qui
ont failli avoir le pays et qui ne l'ont
pas eu
et honnêtement jusqu'au québec depuis
vingt trois ans maintenant le québec est
déjà un pays c'est déjà un pays c'est tu
sors du québec tutoie en ontario tu sais
c'est pas le même pays
c'est pas le même canada tu vas tu tues
tu vas de toronto et à vancouver à
calgary
nous c'est le même pays tout ça a l'air
d'être un autre état des états unis
tu arrives au québec intérieur donc
culturellement et je pense que la
culture la culture est propre
probablement le la sphère la plus la
plus
je pensais la chose à laquelle on adhère
en sa tâche la plus passionnée de la
manière la plus personnelle main
personnes quitteraient portant sur
l'économique que sur les oeuvres de jean
marc vallée
écoute non mais à cause exacte la
culture ta langue ta musique ton cinéma
ton ton ta façon de parler d'exprimer
avec tout ce qui la composent et tous
les mélanges qui la font c'est ce qui
fait de toi toi et j'ai l'impression
commencé à comprendre que qu'on le
veuille ou pas qu'on accepte ou pas
quand on est québécois quand on y vit
depuis un certain nombre d'années on se
rend compte que on vit dans un pays où
qu'il est culturellement mais qui ne
l'est pas administrativement et qu'il ya
des gens qui sont battus pour que ça
fasse du sens pour que culture et
politique phase 1 et qu'ils ont essayé
une fois avec rené lévesque ça n'a pas
marché ils ont essayé avec parisot ça
peut marcher mais c'est wes cette plaie
en dur encore je la vois ça je me suis
dit à chaque fois que je me bats être
des gens dans l'industrie que je leur
dis amen vous voyez pas qu'à passer de
ci de ça à la télé puis lisbonne soit
ouvertement non c'est pas notre combat
ou pas du tout mais que je sens que avec
la lenteur la lenteur avec laquelle les
choses évoluent ne me confirme que yam
manque de volonté de la part de certains
décideurs
je me dis mais ça doit venir d'un lieu
psychologique que je comprends pas et
c'est là que j'ai eu envie de comprendre
et j'ai compris je pense sans prétention
avoir compris qu'il ya des gens d'un
certain âge des québécois blancs d'un
certain âge qui souffrent de ce fait ne
pas avoir un pays qu'ils ont toujours
voulu et donc on a du mal à donner de la
place aux autres parce qu'il ya un refus
il ya un code quand quand on veut qu'on
veut on refuse la la possibilité même de
la théorie
jusqu'à intellectuellement pas besoin
d'aller dans l'île d'un ne fut-ce que
dans les faits je veux dire papa papa
intellectuellement juste dans les faits
la théorie même du racisme et systémique
c'est qu'il ya un braquage on ne veut
pas y aller on veut pas comprendre par
très mal compris c'est très mal compris
mais puisque la question la seule
question à la base de ce c est ce qu est
ce qui m ont statistiquement on voit le
désavantage c'est une mine est très
visible au québec en termes socio
économiques et en terme d'emploi tout se
sait la réponse est oui mais on a la
réponse à ces questions alors qu'on voit
pas pourquoi c'est si un si gros débat
parce qu'il ya des économistes des
sociologues qui qui se base sur des
études
d'autres économistes et sociologues
américains qui sont capables de montrer
des statistiques qui contredit ces
théories qui sont capables de dire que
depuis les années
je sais pas moi 80 ou 90 quand et blanc
dans un milieu on va dire mi rural me
industriels tandis que dans des villes
comme comme détroit par exemple ou qui
qui sont partis en faillite ou qu'être
blanc finalement n'est pas
nécessairement un avantage par rapport à
un noir qui qui va pouvoir bénéficier de
certains programmes sociaux quand le
régime et démocrates par exemple louer
mais c'est très difficile de se baser
sur ces sites sur des statistiques parce
que en donner j'étais curieux puis j'ai
lu certains rapports justement sur asti
des rapports sur le crime aux états unis
combien de personnes blanches se font
tuer par la police versus combien de
noirs et les données de base selon le
camp qu'elle tu appartiens peuvent être
manipulées comme tu veux pour avoir le
résultat qui prouve en point la
statistique c'est des chiffres puis les
chiffres toujours avec comme tu veux si
tu as envie de jouer a qu'un des
chiffres qui correspondent à un bassin
d'une population dans une ville
spécifiques
reflète pas la majorité de l'état par
exemple bah tu peux dire dans cette
ville puis tu dis bon on va pas dire
dans cette ville on va dire dans
plusieurs villes et a prêté à dire
finalement dans cet état voici les
chiffres
moi monsieur madame tout le monde j'ai
pas le temps d'aller fouiller dans les
dents dans le dans les textes écrits par
des sociologues driver liés ou non aux
compagnies je vous dis quelque chose qui
m'a été tweetée ça m'a l'air d'un
document officiel site web
ça m'a l'air de quelque chose de fait
chaud de légers puis j'ai le goût de
croire que je suis informé s'il ya ça
aussi le secteur en algues ou de penser
qu'on est informé parce que ça nous on a
l'impression d'être moins cons puis on
ça passe bien dans un souper de famille
après deux verres de vin
ça nous rend intéressant on a lu un
petit bout d'un rapport qui a été écrit
par je ne sais qui ça me fait toujours
et parce qu'un bijou une étude d que
l'étude de qu'ils pensent une étude
d'ibm et smith et les jets je pense si
tu vas à la télé qui dit une étude dit
que ça vient de légitimité de légitimer
ton propos datent d'au moins 60% dès
qu'on vit dans ce monde d'information et
est donc tout ça pour dire que les
statistiques
tu peux les petits peut dire ce que tu
veux avec les statistiques mais dans les
faits dans les faits - je sais que quand
je vais à l'adisq en 2018
je suis assis dans la salle avec ma
blonde je regarde si ce pas sur scène il
n'ya pas un noir il n'ya pas un arabe ya
pas un latino qui monte sur scène pour
chanter pour recevoir un prix
cet indicateur a aussi après on va me
dire les plus courageux de parmi ceux
qui qui nie la théorie du cices du
racisme systémiques ont dit oui à une
question nombre qu'en plus de blancs que
de noirs et d'arabes et de la tinée au
québec et c'est là que je dis là nuance
j'apporte mon et philosophique parce que
je me dis bah il y à ce qu'un peuple
cet outil de parler de peuple mais il y
a un groupe de personnes qui ont produit
une culture et cette culture va au delà
de ce qu'ils représentent
numériquement ouais c'est ça c'est un
excellent point une excellente
distinction a mené parce
qu'effectivement j'avais déjà eu cette
conversation là on parlait d' occupation
2000 la représentativité à l'occupation
de petits puis je pense que c'était il y
avait trois personnes de couleur sur dix
candidats ont été puisqu'ils
représentent en fait somme toute une
statistique assez représentative du
québec comme on le craint été sauf que
la question et pas juste une donnée
statistique je pense au niveau de la
représentativité que tu peux parler à ce
sujet là c'est peut-être le petit en
haleine mais c'est que j'ai l'impression
qui à l'image de la société qu'on
voudrait prôné plus que juste de
s'arrêter à une statistique qui englobe
la population globale
oui en terme de représentativité
statistiquement probablement qu'on n'est
pas si loin de la réalité statistique du
québec tu parce que je sais pas c'est
quoi la statistique mais dont deux
personnes blanches au québec mais sera
peut-être une majorité frappante le tue
oui bah qu'aucun puis c'est un point qui
est simple - qui peut encore une fois
c'est un plan qui peut ce qui peut se
défendre
oui mais je s'exprimer que les deux
visions la violence et sur ses
statistiques et celles qu'on voudrait
oui oui tout à fait mais où est tout à
fait tout à fait ça se défend après il
ya le fallait dans le fond de deux de
ces choses là j'avais entendu un moment
donné une productrice de télé d'hier le
public québécois a besoin de se
reconnaître quand il regarde nos
fictions les fictions con qu'on produit
donc une approche purement
sociologiquement un statistiques puis
mai
mais si dans son statut mais à caen qui
a dit le mot public québécois réfère
public blanc québécois le problème c'est
que je plais reste nommé référé
clairement public blanc est quoi le
québec s'est notamment deux régions
ouais je voudrais gens consomment c'est
ce média là aussi tu es frangy sens en
dix ans les québécois de région
majoritairement blancs qui regardent
district 31 qui regardent unités neuves
ou je sais pas quoi
il faut qu'y voir québec qui est propre
à leur acquis alors biais cognitifs avec
cette idée de faux pas trop brusquer les
gens faut conforter les gens dans ce
qu'ils pensent être c'est hélas il ya
deux façons de voir les choses dit est
ce que l'art la culture donc la fiction
aussi n'est pas là aussi pour élever les
choses ya peut-être ça la les plus
belles formes de littérature et les plus
grandes formes de musique ont été celles
est celle qui resteront celles qui
resteront sont celles qui bouscule le
statu quo c'est ça et je pense mais
c'est pas celles qui font rouler
l'économie et pipi dans le système dans
lequel on est mais ça peut cesser et
puis je vois la même chose dans la
musique je vois la même chose de manière
globale dont je parlais tout à l'heure
avec avec quelqu'un qui dans dans les
dents dans les dents les ressources
naturelles qui travaille beaucoup en
afrique qui essaie de ramener une
certaine humanité ou ou à l'exploitation
des des ressources minières en afrique
etc et ses global c'est dans toutes les
industries
c'est que il ya je pense que j'ai eu
c'est générationnel si je pense que les
gens qui sont au pouvoir de ces
industries là et donc les industries
culturelles aussi ont connu un modèle
qui était ce qui est qui qui entre à
nous de mourir dans tous les sens et que
donc il faut s'accrocher à tout prix au
peu qu'on a donc prendre le moins de
risques possibles dont justifié par tous
les moyens possibles les raisons pour
lesquelles on n'est pas prête à prendre
de risques
mais même en termes de business ça fait
plus de sens de rejoindre le monde parce
que si tu regardes netflix tous les
choses encadrement est ce que l'histoire
c'est multi multi multi tout ce que tu
veux
multi identitaire le monde et ça ouais
ouais on ne peut pas juste de passer sur
tes petites statistiques propres à un
endroit où au québec ou au canada pour
justifier le fait que temps mais pas
plus le monde est comme ça ça tu extrait
du monde tu dis non nous on est nous qui
ont fait les choses comme on commet le
sang c'est pas comme ça que tu élèves
telle est la société au niveau des
autres ouais c'est ça au dessus des
autres
ouais c'est ça ou alors tu tu assumes
studio non moi je suis je pas envie j'ai
pas le goût de prendre des risques
c'est ça que je fais mais géra gérant
les présenter sous estimé l'intelligence
la capacité d'empathie ton public
j'ai l'impression que merci tu vois un
personnage merci il s'unit minorités
visibles qui votent merci des situations
auxquelles tu te reconnais ou qui vident
et votre capable d'empathie quand même
le sait vraiment de des hommes et non
mais c'est pas ça ne me ressemble pas
donc je peux pas connectés et il ya
d'autres choses sur lesquelles on
connecte dans un document que la couleur
claque la porte et c'est là la série de
ses os ils sont allés vraiment ils ont
essayé de ratisser le plus large
pacifique cite des personnes de couleur
des personnes grosses têtes toutes
lettres et puis moi le personnage que je
joue au casino d'esprit le plus c'est le
frère noir quelques uns des traits de
caractère on ramasse semblables c'est
basique comme celui type ce n'est pas
l'autre frère qui est blanc physiquement
je pourrais m'identifie plus à lui que
je modifierai ouais mon ex mon ex
capitaine ses tripes sur la musique
r'n'b sont plus grande idole d'enfance
c'est bien de ses fils ont pu que c'est
la personne qui en tant que jeune fille
adolescente qu'à regarder tchèque qui
l'inspirait c'est bien puisqu'ils te
laisser sa trace à la sas que tu viens
de dire
c'est probablement ce qui est lustre de
la manière la plus forte
l'espoir que j'ai c'est à dire que c'est
pour ça que je mise beaucoup sur la
jeune génération les enfants en bas âge
et je vois leurs amis je sais pas quel
âge ton ex mais je mise beaucoup sur
cette génération de gens qui ne qui ont
qui ont les une certaine culture on va
dire qu'une culture noire à la fondation
à la fondation même de leur identité
alors même qu'ils ne sont pas noirs tous
les jeunes qui rentrent en écoutant du
rap n'est qu'ainsi que la mort jeudi
c'est ça les modèles la ccig exactement
je ne pense pas je pars je pense pas que
des cyniques qui pensent que le
consommateur blanc moyen de hip hop le
consomme comme comme on consomme 10 m
dos où l'on prend puis on jette puis pas
nécessairement moi je pense qu'il ya des
jeunes blancs qui consomment du 15 juin
et du jayco du coup même des choses on
va dire qu'ils peuvent sembler un peu
plus en surface moins en surface et je
sais pas
tous les babies la de baby loup baby
mais qui qui tripent sur cette musique
là comme moi je tripe est sûre sur le
rugby des années 90 quand j'étais jeune
sourd
nos managers quand j'ai quand j'avais 15
ans ou est salée construit donc ils sont
construits par quelque chose dont les
parents sont en train de dire oui mais
c'est quand même autre chose
mais les jeunes sentent renoncer nous ça
c'est nous et nous sommes sas et c'est
un nouveau monde c'est réellement un
nouveau monde
puis je m'en suis rendu compte quand je
parlais à des gens qui avaient des
enfants ados des gens comme véronique
cloutier par exemple c'est parce que
j'étais curé jeu tout comme ce walk nice
tout d'un coup la de beaucoup de gens
dans la quarantaine mi-quarantaine
blanche qui qui ont décidé que la sté le
temps de se réveiller puis que le
racisme ça existe et puis ça n'avait pas
d'alluré
à quel point c'est sincère je me suis
rendu compte que ce qu'il était vraiment
ce qui était réellement sincère dans
cette prise de conscience s'est pas
venue d'une illumination elles n'ont pas
commencé à se sont pas retrouvés l'ont
pas trouvée retrouver le bouddhisme peas
horizons ils ont changé du jour au
lendemain annoncé leurs enfants c'est
lawrence seller kids qui comme ton ex
disent non c'est nous ça il n'y a pas de
de weid pas de murs nous on a grandi
dans un monde où c'est pour ça que le
symbolisme c'est beaucoup plus important
que les gens à penser des gens qui sont
politiquement cynique qui disent heureux
long mais juste des gens devant d'été au
quesne puis tout ça moi je moi je dis
que le taux kane est important
le temps qu'elle a une importance qui ne
s'évaluent que deux décennies plus tard
au moment où on voit le toqué non peu de
sinik puis on peut dire ah bah ouais tu
te fais avoir pitel en gros 100 m crawl
105 me davis jo n'y aurait pas eu de
de mon côté je sais pas quoi puis dans
le hip hop n'existerait pas et c'était
l'été au quesne de l'époque les sidney
poitier compagnie il y en a qu il était
un peu plus ou moins que d'autres mais
ils sont fait traiter de tokai donc ton
ex le les ados les enfants de véronique
cloutier les tous et toute cette
génération de gens qui se disent non non
ça c'est une chose vu comme une petite
vidéo instagram pendant en plein belem
l'autre comme poste jo-wilfried une
jeune fille qui en train d'expliquer à
ses parents qui ont rien compris
puis deux points de vue complètement
cédé parents complètement opaque j'en ai
un qui rend point mais non mais exagère
pis non pas par un moment on ne
comprenait pas la gare il avait à un
genou sur son cou il en est mort juste
parce qu'il était noir pas pour autre
chose non pas et on a filmé ses
collègues étaient autour puis est-ce que
tu comprends qu'il ya quand même de quoi
le blé par an comprenez rien mais c'est
ce qui te là qui m'intéressent
et quand les parents quand ce que si ce
qu'eads avait pas comment ça finit leur
conversation mais je peux imaginer que
dans certains foyers
les parents ont dit je suis parent j'ai
le goût pompiers de même qu'ils pensent
que je suis qui m'apprécient qui
m'admirent si je pense que je dois piler
sur sur mes convictions fait convictions
passées pour essayer d'avoir un terrain
d'entente avec mon kit je vais le faire
et je pense qu'il ya eu ce petit
changement et j'ai vu des femmes et des
hommes blancs dire j'ai de quoi
apprendre de mes enfants ils sont en
train de me dire que le monde change
puis je veux peut-être à embarquer sur
le bateau si je peux être complètement
dépassées et c'est ça ce que tu viens de
me dire je je je je
ça m'apporte beaucoup d'espoir c'est des
gens qui sont nés dans un monde où le
président des etats-unis barack obama
par exemple tu peux penser ce que tu
veux de son sexe que sa politique de ce
qu'il est ce réellement est ce qu'il a
vraiment changé la cause des noirs dans
les tons d'effets pratiques et
pragmatiques économiquement
factuellement peut-être que pas tant que
ça je ne le sais pas je suis pas un jeu
pas un spécialiste mais une chose qu'il
a changé c'est le symbole il a changé il
a il a donné à son élection
même ce même si cette même s'il a été
mis en piste en place par wall street je
m'en fous il a changé quelque chose de
très important
il a donné à une génération de jeunes
noirs ou d'autres quelque chose que moi
j'ai pas eu moins qu'en chine est le
président de la plus grande puissance du
monde
c'est un régal et après c'était bush le
père peu après cet écrin tnp reprise des
bouches le fils c'est tout ce que j'ai
connu de la puissance ç'a toujours été
blanc symboliquement ce gala est arrivé
puis avait lu puis avec sa femme
première première dame blanche
symboliquement très très fort et ça
change les choses dans l'esprit des gens
et quand une est dans un monde qui est
comme ça tu as beau de faire expliquer
que ça fait des décennies que que
l'homme et des est au top de l'échelle
sociale
ça veut pas dire la même chose attend qu
à tes parents pour toi être blanche
juste une couleur ses collections et on
s'en rend pas compte encore aujourd'hui
mais dans 20 ans on regardera en arrière
peut on dire à asté ça le changement
je pense qu'on vit dans une époque tout
à fait révolutionnaire parce qu'elle a
jamais eu autant de décalage culturel
entre les enfants et leurs parents
moi quand j'étais petit la culture de
mes parents à quelques différences près
en tout cas j'essaie de calquer ma
culture puis mon comportement à celui de
mai par bondy fois la rébellion à l'est
jusqu'à la musique que j'écoutais au
delà de ça pas grand chose le modèle
c'était mes parents même à l'adolescence
c'est quand tu rentres à l'âge où te dis
parents ils ont incompris
je suis quand même ce petit chemin style
et arrivent à l'âge adulte jeune adulte
dit bah finalement comme là j'ai
l'impression que c'est pas une canne
j'ai vraiment l'impression que les ados
d'aujourd'hui sont ailleurs par rapport
à leurs parents culturellement en termes
d'identité les identifiants éclaté tu
peut naître un homme peut décider que tu
es une femme
par exemple ma mère est en rébellion est
en ado a versé par an mais c'est un tout
autre combat c'était la religion cette
hystérie une toute autre époque c'est
maintenant les convois on est rendu
vraiment ailleurs mais ce changement
alors maintenant il faut qu'ils se
traduisent en réelle représentativité
maintenant parce que la culture
afro-américaine petit roman la culture
finalement la plus influente au nom si
on prend juste musicalement le blues le
jazz maintenant les pop la musique la
plus importante le rock n roll music
fondamentalement noir aborde le titre la
musique la puce ne plus écouter le plus
importante partout dans le monde
mais louis où il subsiste un problème si
vous êtes tous les gars qui venu ici
c'est ben pourquoi encore à ce jour
mettons tous les rapports simon sera pas
de l'école de pensée que j'ai testé
blanc où je pense tu peux faire du
rappelé je tirais aucun problème avec ça
mais il faut quand même que c'est il
subsiste un problème qui inquiète encore
aujourd'hui les seuls artistes rap ou
québec qui joue à la radio sont blancs
c'est ça et ça c'est là tu as touché à
quelque chose à le grand mystère de la
radio à côte
j'en ai parlé avec webster j'en ai parlé
avec vers une clio par cast aussi
reparler avec une collabo let puis c'est
un grand mystère
je t'avoue que sais-je est un grand
mystère j'ai l'impression que deux
choses en fait
daniel bélanger venu sur le podcast puis
des caisses qui avait remarqué dans son
auditoire qui a changé avec les années
c'est qu'avant les enfants pour
illustrer ce que tu faisais les enfants
ça bien comme leurs parents puis
maintenant qu'un qui voit un jeune
parent avec un enfant rue c'est le
parent pauvre
il est renversé m tant pis pour
peut-être pour lancer une piste de
réflexion dans pourquoi est-ce que ça se
matérialise pas encore ses clés les
jeunes parents moi je considère que même
temps nous on est prof possiblement plus
dans la catégorie parents qu enfin dans
ce discours le théâtre entente il ya des
jeunes parents qui ont cet âge là pis
qui puisse un jour nous on est né bien
avant barack obama gatel présidente
effet que les gens qui ne les jeunes qui
naissent en ce moment c'est que les
jeunes parents encore j'ai l'impression
que les preneurs de décisions sont au
dessus de cette génération là celle ci
nous prenons nos décisions et on leur
jeu n'ont pas rempli c'était le 3 fera
tant qu'un lahoud est allé à tout le
monde en parle depuis
puis le guettait la joue un peu buté qui
le mit et anciennement propriétaire
d'une station de radio puis regardez là
où dieu jam quand j'ai entendu ta
musique
c'est la première fois que je me
reconnais c'est dans durable mais lors
des raids sur la banlieue
la banlieue les hommes blancs mais c'est
vrai vous avez volé l'entrevue de la ccx
est parfois j'entends du rap que je me
reconnaissais fièrement connectés que la
tragédie c'est que je connecte des bleus
c'est quand même ok mais parce que c'est
des gars comme toi vraiment des hommes
blancs au dessus de 60 ans comme toi qui
décides la direction éditoriale des
radios des chaînes de télé de toutes les
médias traditionnels comme on les
connaît
puis ces gens là ont pas encore fait le
pont avec moi j'ai le feeling et quand
les preneurs de décisions vont être des
soit des jeunes parents qui que leurs
enfants un menso véreux ou carrément
d'en face aux heureuses dans cinquante
ans les enfants qui n'avaient pas qui
naissent mais qui grandissent en ce
moment avec toute cette culture noire le
mélo qui vont arriver entre les preneurs
aux décisions ils vont être beaucoup
plus réceptif à faire jouer du 6e sur
les radios francophones qui avait joué
du loud mettons le cac et a grandi pitt
a écouté tous les albums de des call
back to back même site même si mon
enfant blanc quand on est rendu à
diriger
une direction éditoriale une radio mais
ça se peut très bien que tu es beaucoup
plus à l'écouté de toutes les diversités
en fait absolument j'ai l'impression que
sa part du top 4 le top c'est quand même
faudrait va passer une nouvelle garde un
peu gêné assure ce absolument absolument
pilotes arrivés à hama à la conclusion à
laquelle je suis arrivé un peu
tardivement malheureusement mais je suis
arrivé c'est de dire arrêtons de
demander puis d'exiger quoi que ce soit
aux dirigeants en place aujourd'hui ça
peut mettre un petit peu de pression
puis on veut on peut peut-être avoir un
petit peu de 2
on peut avoir deux un petit peu de
changements bois fois un petit peu de
changements mais mes calculs et 10 parce
que on avec les réseaux sociaux on n'a
pas envie de 2de bac rush du du monde ou
aux que deux donc on vous donnait un
petit brin de quelque chose pour pour
apaiser le bruit mais le vrai changement
il viendra tout seul par la force des
choses et ce sera une question de
génération on est forcément on s'en va
forcément vers là on va toujours avoir
des critères de division mais dans
quelques années ce sera plus une
question de couleur sera plus une
question ça va être autre chose
je pense que les divisions sociales
malheureusement vont subsister encore un
petit bout et je pense que c'est la
prime c'est le ça qui est intéressant
c'est que si on devait avoir de vrais
critères de division et devrait être
social et non ethnique ou mais on ya un
système au dessus de nous qui a réussi
par ce site nous distraire pour qu'on ne
pose pas trop de questions pour qu'on
demande pas trop d'explications qui a
fini par nous faire croire que nous
étions d'abord ce à quoi nous
ressemblions physiquement ce à quoi nous
disions croire spirituellement
alors que c'est pas ça c'est pas ça il
ya beaucoup plus de 2
si tu mets dans une pièce des gens qui
se demandent tous comment ça se fait que
dans un pays comme le canada encore des
enfants qui manquent de petit déjeuner
tu vas trouver des gens de toutes
couleurs et de toutes orientations
sexuelles ou religieuses mais pour
empêcher ces questionnements là parce
que si ces questions s'il y avait une
mobilisation de ses préoccupations l'un
serait la guerre civile on serait tous
dans la rue parce qu'il ya tellement de
choses j'ai tellement d'incongruités
social tellement de choses qui font pas
de sens comment on vit dans un pays un
des pays les plus riches au monde qui a
encore des enfants qui mangent pas qu'à
des écoles qui restent inondés pikine
qui pourrait les murs pour réseaux les
quelques nausées que nos aînés s'emballa
on l'a vu à quelques vides lorsque nos
aînés sont comme abandonnée il ya tout
un tas de questions de ré d'injustice
réel qui risquerait de réellement
mobiliser une vraie majorité contre un
système
mais on est tellement distrait à se
regarder à dire un noir blanc musulmans
ceux ci puis on y croit on est comme on
ait craqué comme ce comme ça nous
divisaient réellement puis quand tu le
vois quand on en est conscient et que tu
essaies de te faire ça tu te rends
compte qu'être la résistance la ccc ça
va loin la saison ont cessé dans notre
histoire c'est dans nos c'est dans notre
éducation dis chiche
quand tu n'a connu que ça c'est
difficile avait avec avec toute la bonne
foi et la volonté du monde on peut bien
exiger plus de diversité plus de 6 plus
de ça c'est pas les gens qui sont au top
aujourd'hui qu'ils vont changer
moi c'est ça mais comme se dit le
changement viendra mettez pour le jeune
militant de 20 ans l'universitaire
y a pas envie d'attendre à 60 ans pour
voir le changement se comprend on
l'impression que lui va le faire le
chanvre ont eu à contribuer au
changement je parle de moi moi je parle
des vieux
non mais dans le sens qui sait ce que le
changement va arriver un jour ou l'autre
mais je pense que c'est quand même
normal qu'elle ait certains gens qui
soient plus pressés à le vois pas ce
qu'ils font ils veulent vivre ces jeux
cela fait tellement longtemps
ça fait tellement longtemps qu'on compte
toujours le l'exemple de james baldwin
le grand écrivain afro américains qui
n'étaient pas dire c'est même les les
démocrates les plus les plus
bienveillants me dise china minsheng
jusqu'à moi je leur dis mais wind moi ça
fait ça fait moi et ma famille ça fait
depuis des décennies qu'on attend qu'on
me dit que ça va mieux puis le civil
rights movement a l'air de changer les
choses mais quand caen quand obama est
élu président puis violences policières
les conséquences du raid mining puis le
fait d'isoler une certaine population
noire dans des coins où ils n'ont aucun
avenir économique
titanic sont encore là weng weng weng
puis je comprends l'impatience
évidemment chaud je comprends
l'impatience pitié mais tend maintenant
mater bas-côté n'entend pas caste il dit
je t'ai je peux vu dans un monde ou
presque et on se met à compter le nombre
des blancs le nombre de noix le nombre
des sites habilités raciale exactement
sur sur scène dans une émission tout ce
qui m'est gmt pearson vue notamment de
l'ouest que tout est réglementé et puis
l'écouté on voudrait tous d'un monde où
ça se fait naturellement
ouais sauf que la réalité c'est
aujourd'hui ça se fait pas naturellement
c'est fait qu'est ce qu'on fait avec ça
quelles solutions retrouve pitié mettons
en béton lui va s'opposer à des quotas
mettez dans l'optique où comme tu disais
plus tôt le token est important même si
même si triste un peu à dire ouais ben
le touriste parce que l'on s'arrête sur
le mot ce qu'il a ce à quoi il
correspond historiquement on on parle
aux annexes de mai on pense au [ __ ] de
maison aux etats-unis' comme ça ça vient
avec des images de très très fortes dans
nos têtes
mais le toqué ce n'est ni plus ni moins
que quelqu'un qui fait c'est ça offre de
symboles et c'est un sacrifier quelque
part c c c est ok n'y a pas de cessez
pas une job ça parce que dans la vie
mais toutes parts se mettre toute
personne noire que je connais qui a
atteint un certain niveau de popularité
dans l'ouest francophone parce que c'est
pas une c'est une autre réalité met hors
jeu par litre de la france et du québec
que je connais très bien toute personne
noire qui a connu un qui a connu le top
une certaine notoriété a été choqués
d'un certain monde s'est retrouvé dans
une situation toq'r où tu as dû dire
tout cela c'était d'arriver
comment ça m'est arrivé je considère ce
oui c'est ça m'est déjà arrivé et ça
m'est déjà arrivé puis cce
c'est dans le sait même pas c'est pas si
évident dans la manière dont s'était
proposé c'est toi avec ton bagage
psychologique comme personne noire qui
reconnaît ce qui est en train de se
passer et qui se dit ah j'étais
probablement pas le plan à il ya eu une
actualité chaude
certains médias qui doivent forcément
strange et à gauche parce que
c'est une certaine gauche qui sont
financés en tout cas c'est l'or c'est
leur truc
il doit faire un geste assez drôle tout
d'un coup je me suis je me retrouve un
plan à la tf1 n'a pas sonné depuis six
mois puis là on voit là on m'appelle bon
qu'est ce que je fais et moi dans ces
situations ça m'est arrivé pendant porno
c'est que ces pays a d'autres qui vont
pouvoir te lire j'ai eu des discussions
avec d'autres artistes noirs qui ont
connu la même chose
et la question qui se pose moi
personnellement j'ai pas le coup j'ai
pas le goût et après tu te dis mais si
j'y suis à qui ça sert et comment est-ce
que moi si je suis un petit enfant noir
et que je regarde la télé
mettons un petit enfant noir adopté avec
mes parents regardent la fête nationale
à tenir et que je vois une personne qui
me ressemble qui semble être là au même
titre que tous les autres
est-ce que ça a une valeur pour moi
immense est ce que j'aurai envie de
priver ça cette personne à cette
personne juste pour mon ego personnel de
j'ai pas envie d'être le toque nba
non non mais j'attendais lebron james
est un grand fan de basketball lebron
james a amené s'est fait poser quel sens
parce que dernièrement les communes
une tendance que les joueurs il ya
personne l'aude management le fait que
les joueurs
joue pas quelques matchs de temps en
temps pour se reposer c'est lui le fait
pas lui je tout les game piscine ou
demander pourquoi il dit parce que c'est
emmener jeu suite à la télé puis qu'un
enfant qui me voient jouer qui salent
inspire qu'ils y moi aussi je veux faire
ce lundi je veux avoir le plus de
chances possibles de farce et je veux
jouer tout le temps joue à être le plus
souvent la même si des fois je prendrai
ben du repos puis j'irai pas passer un
temps de pause et je me dis peut-être
qui en ce moment je re changer la vie
d'une seule personne qui est celle qui
me regardent qui dit ça se peut se
poudrer - égalité des chances des
opportunités en ce moment je dirais être
l'arbre à représentativité mettons qui
serait évidemment représentative du
pourcentage de population on n'y est pas
aussi avec son attaque ça certes
naturellement mais ça sera peut-être
jamais ou soit sinon l'autre solution
c'est on réglemente ce qui me semble
plus quelque chose de si farfelue que
ouais c'est ça c'est les fameux quotas
puis premièrement je pense qu'il faut il
faut changer le lexique des choses de
base il attend ça sonne un peu permis de
paille chose c'est que tu veux pas dire
on veut on veut régler un problème de
discrimination en disant discrimination
positive
pas comme tata tata perdu les gens là gg
et c'est là que tu vois la mauvaise foi
de certains décident décideurs parce que
je me suis toujours posé la question que
j'ai un ami qui est pompier qui est
blanc qui m'a dit écoute du jour au
lendemain notre chef de station venu me
dire ben falloir engager des pompiers
noirs et il m'a dit bon ça nous semble à
nous une façon nous imposer un profil
qui n'a rien à voir avec la job
un pompier noir qui a qui sera un super
bon pompier je m'en fous qu'il soit noir
ou thaïlandais ou sri lankais je m'en
fous complètement
mais mais avec mes gars on a
l'impression que on nous impose quelque
chose qui qui
et tout au pire qu'on peut remettre en
question et c'est là que je trouve qu'il
ya une mauvaise foi de la part des
décideurs
parce que si tu veux vraiment pas ce que
c'est d'accord avec toi il faut faire
quelque chose et donc il faut il faut le
faire mais tu peux pas annoncer que tu
vas le faire
on différentie site si ton but c'est de
réellement faire un changement
tulasne on sport et le fait le pas ce
que tu sais très bien que l'annoncé
s'est créé une scission dès le départ et
crée la possibilité d'avoir justement de
polariser puis que finalement tu te
retrouves à ne plus rien faire d'avoir
des acteurs blancs qui viennent d'iran
mais l'homme était meilleur que cette
personne mais qui a été choisi oui puis
d'avoir des actes des noirs ou des
arabes des latinos que son fait engager
se dire mais ce que je mets beaucoup je
suis là parce que je remplis un quota
c'est bon pour personne
tu comprends faites-le que quand ils
disent on va faire quelque chose donc on
va non c'est pas des dieux pas c'est
juste le faire si on peut pas placer la
discrimination positive quand c'est
juste des cidres et a mené le bal en a
quelque chose de plus égale le t6 si je
te demande ou à l'adisq exemple c'est
que des blancs c'est pas la
discrimination possible de dire il
devrait avoir un petit peu plus de
diversité c'est juste essayer de trouver
l'égalité la pression en tant que
personnes blanches site prendre ce c'est
ce que quelque part le site était
habituée d'avoir toute la tarte au
complet ben il faut peut-être falloir
qu'ils foutent force il faut aussi aller
5 points temps quelque part j'étais
content une stratégie
j'ai appliqué sur une job team et moi
qui prône thivras réellement
profondément 6 des loges appliqué sur
une job de profs aussi les cinq fois ci
dans l'application pour nous pondre dans
l'application igo à m'emmener ils disent
on on est et on favorise ont tourné un
programme de inclusif quand on en a donc
coché si vous êtes une femme ou
minorities et pis
évidemment je cache pas pitié au moment
du procès ces 15 ne te dis ben je viens
de me nuire
mes chances un peu d'envolées jobs
serait probablement quelqu'un à talent
égal cochant cette case je leur ai dit
je dis en tant que personnes blanches
que tous les privilèges dans la ville
réellement notre démo sexuelle bonne
famille blanc tout ce que tu veux je me
dis crem a été je considère que j'ai les
capacités le talent pour faire ce job là
en même temps je me dis si vraiment mes
actions reflète mes idéaux je vais être
content que une femme
à talent égal elle adore oui mais c'est
toujours de faire son bout de chemin oui
c'est très dur de faire ce bout de
chemin quand tu es dedans puis toi tu
l'as dit tu es un excellent excuse moi
tu es un vrai blanc je dis ça à la
blague c'est un vrai blanc comme moi je
suis pas un vrai noirjean dans le sens
où tu es un vrai blanc dans son stade à
ses privilèges
tu viens d'une bonne famille tu es tu
étais risque hétérosexuels tu es un
homme tous les clichés comme toutes les
cordes mais mettant la place d'un blanc
qui passe aussi vrai que toi inquiète
aussi vrai blanc que toi pas de famille
car il a travaillé à bûcher toute sa vie
comme un malade il vient d'une famille
d'alcoolo puis il s'en est sorti à peine
puis il arrive au même endroit puis les
devants le même petit bout de fait que
toi puis doit cocher cette case le sipal
plusieurs matches en fait c'est plus
difficile de l'accepter
imaginez il a pas il n'a pas le luxe de
cette vision
ouverte mondialistes c'est ce qu'ont
après semaine on présuppose toujours que
on doit toujours être plus que sa propre
personne
on est on est on est rarement plus que
ça on est d'abord nous qui nous sommes
ce qui nous a construit nos blessures
d'enfance nous sommes ça avant toute
autre chose donc exigé à des populations
entières d'être plus que ça par principe
ça marche pas ça marche pas tant qu'il y
en a qui jouent en jeu pour faire
semblant pour exister dans la société
comme comme ton ami qui ose pas dire
qu'elle écoute des deux côtés mais quand
tu vas te coucher le soir tu es toi puis
ce que tu penses ne changera pas de ce
que tu penses tu de ton en justice quand
tu es à les appliquer pour une job ne
changera pas toi tu as le luxe d'avoir
un coussin de bonheur qui est plus grand
que d'autres
donc tu peux c'est un luxe que d'être
c'est un luxe que de pouvoir être
généreux on peut pas exiger le même
niveau de générosité à tout le monde et
je pense que philosophiquement c'est la
queue leu leu l'occident s'est compliqué
la tâche
on a mis la barre beaucoup trop
moralement et on exige beaucoup trop à
tout le monde de la même façon
ça marche pas c'est pour ça que le vivre
ensemble doit passer par l'individu
avant le groupe
c'est pour ça que quand je calque en jeu
contre quand je parle de racisme et tous
âges et j'essaie toujours de parler en
mon nom ne pas de parler au nom de tous
les noirs parce que projet beaucoup plus
de privilèges que beaucoup de blancs
faut que j'en sois conscient si je veux
avoir l'oreille des blancs à qui je
parle
puis les blancs à qui je pars sont en
majorité moins privilégiés que moi je
suis dans une situation très bizarre
prix est très mou il est pourtant je vis
des injustices raciales
ce qu'on appelle des micros
krause agression c'est exact parce que
régulièrement mais qui ne me touche pas
autant qu'une autre personne noire qui
pas aussi privilégié que moi donc c'est
un bonheur qui cause de mon coussin
d'honneur qui est plus important et est
souvent t on ce don à comment comment ce
qu'on leur donne ses commensaux donne
moi je me dis que ma façon de redonner
pour le privilège que j'ai c'est d'être
d'essayer d'être l écoute aux deux
extrémités que je me suis dit c'est quoi
si j'ai dû backlash la part de personnes
noires parce que je semble avoir ou
désirez un lieu de rencontre avec
mathieu bock-côté c'est correct
c'est légitime je comprends de ça vient
d'en avoir une autre vie je réponds
penserez peut-être la même façon dont je
vais être à l écoute de sa 6 g/j si j'ai
un backlash de la part de bach pas
vraiment un backlash même si je reçois
un commentaire d'une personne qui trouve
que je suis une personne blanche qui
trouve que je suis passé reconnaissant
de la place que les bus québec me donne
et que je devrais arrêter d'un plan du
monde de diversité
ici et là je je je dois à la vigie le
cette ouverture d'esprit est cet
amour-là et et suite à aux packers avec
mathieu bock-côté j'ai fait des
entrevues jeunes en particulier la
personne m'a dit 'mais mais tu penses
pas que c'est une façon de deux parce
que je me disais déjà noir privilégiez
donc j'ai aussi beaucoup d'empathie pour
un blanc qui qui a de la misère dans la
vie et qui comprend pas qu'on parle de
privilèges blanc j'ai de l'empathie pour
cette personne et je comprends que cette
personne ne comprennent pas qu'on parle
de privilèges blanc elle n'a pas le luxe
de comprendre ça et je me dis oh mais
c'est pas une façon de 2
de nier la réalité d'une certaine
injustice qui ne vis que le fait d'être
noir puis comme banon moi je le vois pas
comme ça mais si je dois avoir cette
critique
je suis prêt à la prendre et ne pas la
balle et d'un coup de main je suis prête
à l'écouté puis dire ok je comprends
d'où ça vient mais peu utilisé en
interne de quelques minutes tu disais si
j'avais eu une autre vie
possiblement que je penserais comme
sortie ce qui est essentiellement à la
base de tous les les désaccords ou les
points de vue différents types puis
l'optique est dans la réalité la
singularité de chaque vie humaine puis
de chaque expérience humaine amène son
lot d'opinion qui sont différents de là
l'importance de la capable de le
reconnaître puis d'écouter
c'est ça vraiment et puis je pense que
je pense que tu l'expriment super bien
pis peas et c c'est un petit peu sow
city 2-2 d'aller de l'avant puis faire
une entrevue avec mathieu bock-côté en
sachant très bien les messages de tous
le recevoir en étant prêt à accepter le
fait qu'il y réalités sont différentes
puisque les opinions sont différents bah
c'est que j'essaie d'être conséquents
j'essaie d'être conséquents moi je viens
d'un pays qui s'est déchiré
littéralement pour des raisons ethniques
ce qui peut sembler encore plus absurde
si tu parles de blanc conte noir parce
que là c'était noir conte noir et donc
jusqu'où ça va
et la question de la conciliation c'est
que même m'obsède puis je sais juste
d'être conséquent si je veux si je veux
qu'on vive ensemble
ma première préoccupation doit être
l'oreille de ceux qui ne sont pas ou ne
seraient pas d'accord avec moi c'est pas
le rêve de ceux qui pensent comme moi je
veux dire c'est à qui je suis je peux ça
peut être le fun là un barbecue laddh
dire qu'on est d'accord puis qu'on est
mieux que les autres mais ça arrive pas
ne s'arrête pas mon problème
j'essaie vraiment juste d'être
conséquent lorsque les racistes assumer
eux les plus conséquents ils font
beaucoup plus de sens que nous parce
qu'un raciste qui dit je n'en veux pas
du noir
je veux un pays de blanc basta au moins
il est conséquent mais quelqu'un qui est
dit vivons ensemble mais toi part pas
comme tu parles soit pas qui tu es ne
pense pas comme tu penses ça marche pas
il ya comme un manque de cohérence là ce
qui est exprimé un petit peu plus tôt le
tir par rapport justement c'est à
l'homme blanc mais qui serait qu'ils
auraient une vie parce que c'est pas
tout on connaît pas la vie des gentils
qui sait ce qui donc ses défauts sur des
faux sur les réseaux sociaux on voit des
commentaires assez violent on va ajouter
de dates dans tous les sens ce métier
pour moi la critique dire ta gueule tu
es un homme tu étais juste un homme
blanc je peux pas m'exprimer là dessus
c'est comme tous les privilèges mais tu
connais pas la vie des gens tu sais pas
si c'est parce que personne ne paie
c'est juste ça me fait penser à quelque
chose comme mathieu bock-côté m'a dit ça
ça m'a fait quoi on m'a dit ça continue
comme ça ils vont faire de nous des
blancs c'est ce que tu viens c'est ce
que vient de dire c'est que je ne suis
pas sûr dans quelle mesure un homme
blanc hétérosexuel se sent réellement
blanc au québec c'est à dire que dans
quelle mesure est ce que tu marches dans
la rue en disant ce bureau jamais jamais
en fait le fait que de réfléchir à sa
couleur de sa propose extrêmement rares
le temps des scripts
on n'est jamais on a parlé avec nicolas
ouellet pavon a parlé plusieurs fois t
on n'est jamais rappelée au quotidien du
fait qu'on est blanc du mas questionner
sur notre identité et cesser d'être
blanc c'est impressionnant s et ça c'est
un privilège
qui aujourd'hui est retournée c'est vrai
que c'est un privilège parce que moi
toute ma vie j'étais conscience du fait
que j'étais consciente du fait que
j'étais noir
toute ma vie je le suis tout le temps
c'est un privilège que de ne pas se
poser ces questions-là de ma vie de ne
pas vivre avec ce fardeau là par contre
c'est un désavantage
quinze jours se réveiller et de ceux de
se faire reprocher métier c'est juste
que tu joues les est ce qu'on peut
présupposer qu'une personne une petite
vie facile et sans problème c'est vrai
fait qu'elle soit un homme qui selon
elle sont hétérosexuels que tu connais
pas les petits sites à passer des choses
horribles dans un environnement est pu
l'être humain est bon à cacher c'est
roman ouais on est on est bon là dedans
fact et j'ai de la misère avec ses 7
cette rapidité à assumer delà de quel
point quelqu'un de la ouate dans les
quelqu'un aurait supposément grandi
simple fait qu'elle soit blanche après
ce rêve que une même personne béton
blanche mais avec un venant de d'un
background ayant vécu certains trauma
versus une personne doit avec les mêmes
très mobiles drôlement que la bafin doit
en plus vous vivre avec le fait qu'à soi
quand chaque jour avant peut-être vivre
10 des micros agression et randy mail du
fait qu'elle noir
et puis je dirais pratiquement tous les
invités noir qui sont venus dans ce
studio le on dit qu'il ya certains
points dans leur vie ont été profilés
laitiers par par la police par exemple
des choses et avec laquelle moi je dis
petit tour quotidien des faits qui
restent se risquer à difficultés
également il ya quand même un groupe qui
rend plus celle d' absolument absolument
saas etc
c'est vrai ce qui ce qui ce qui rend la
tâche un peu compliqué c'est faux pour
savourer subi près ce présupposé que le
sept personnes blanches se mettant la
difficulté égale personnes blanches
parce noir noir précarité
économique on va dire peut-être des
problèmes de santé un background
familial complètement dysfonctionnelle
c'est tout ça propose proportionnelle
blanc noir c'est que ça veut dire c'est
que la personne non blanche a quand même
le privilège supplémentaire de par sa
blancheur d'avoir le petit edge qui va
faire en sorte que s'il ya une chance de
s'en sortir la personne blanche s'en
sortira mieux que la personne noire mais
il faut présupposé que la personne
blanche en est convaincue elle ce que
nous on regarde ça de l'extérieur parce
qu'on a des données parce qu'on a des
faits mais l'individu blanc en est il
convaincu pas sûr et c'est pourtant à
cette personne qu'on essaie d'expliquer
qu'elle a un privilège c'est là que ça
devient problématique
c'est d'une part a expliqué la théorie
de ce privilège blanc l'un et de l'autre
se penser qu'on peut mettre ça dans le
dans le sait c'est que c'est quasiment
de bout pour le poteau mise et la
personne pour pour changer la
psychologie de cette personne et elle
lui fait faire en sorte cette personne
soit réellement habité par cette réalité
là par cette compréhension là des choses
ce qui est quasi impossible
c'est là que ça devient difficile c'est
pour ça que les notions de du privilège
blanc versus le manque de privilèges
pour les personnes racisées ça doit
quasiment être secondaire parce que
quand moi je l' ai vu ses joues soit je
parle à une personne blanche qui va me
dire oh ouais je comprends mais
généralement la personne qui dit je
comprends c'est une personne qui
qui est consciente de son privilège il
faut être conscient de son privilège
pour pouvoir en accepter la théorie si
tu ne comprends pas ton privilèges
jamais tu embarques rats dans mon délire
ça marche pas et pourtant moi j'exige de
toi que tu le comprennent pour qu'enfin
je puisse dire il ya une chance qu'on
vive ensemble ça marche comme pas je
sais pas si je m'exprime bien là mais
c'est très c'est ça le problème avec les
théories c'est il ya c c'est toujours
une question de perspective puis encore
une fois la psychologie humaine prime
toujours moi si j'ai six jeux
j'estime que toute ma vie a été une
suite de malheurs l'une est la suite de
l'autre blanc pas blanche
seulement rien du tout dans ma ville
tout ce que je vois c'est le meilleur ou
ses malheurs qui est derrière moi et
j'essaie de m'en sortir puis j'essaie de
garder la date est en dehors de loge pas
le luxe de philosophie puis est ce que
le fait d'être noir est toujours te met
toujours en situation de désavantage
parce que c'est ça aussi ça veut dire
c'est à dire que quoi qu'il arrive quand
tu es noir était toujours en situation
de désavantage par rapport à un blanc
peu importe le pays peu importe ce qui
n'est pas toujours vrai c'est pas
toujours vrai mais pas toutes les pays
je pense que quand on la parle de ses
concepts l'on en parle dans le contexte
nord-américain mettons parce qu'ici on
s'en va ailleurs le concept s'applique
même dans le camp ce même dans le
contexte nord américain mais c'est
quelque chose que l'on perd facilement
remarquer c'est qu'on applique aussi la
réalité des états unis au québec qui
courent c'est pas exactement la même
chose en fait c'est pas du tout la même
chose oui ici des injustices mais tiens
on les comprend ce qui se passe est
unique on qu'on la mène ici c'est par un
bloc live majeur il faut que des
débordements
au québec le
pas du tout sauf que la violence
pile à l'urgence du mouvement ont leur
santé au québec aussi mais au québec on
dirait que c'était un peu pauvre bois
comparativement notre réalité le laisser
comme cette année on est ensemble dans
un parc
je peux aussi te rappelles ça venait de
se passer le black night mayor est
ensemble dans un pack cet été puis là
les policiers qui s'en viennent pour
pour parce qu'il était rendu proche de
11 rafale et quitter le parti pris est
du monde avec qui on était qui était pas
d amis qui étaient du monde dont avait
rencontré soirée lamée clés qui sont mis
à tabarnak après la police tu puisses
était dans le temps de défendre de
police ces choses là puis moi je me
rappelle est resté juste avoir fait
qu'il semble que la réalité du québec
c'est pas du tout la prise aux lettres
sur lt policier charles dullin police
oui la police si c'est icontrol
probablement plus les personnes noires
que les personnes blanches au québec ça
a été prouvé le ti sauf que il n'y a
personne ici qu'en ce moment encore le
cas qui voit des policiers arrivés avec
les outils que de mal et même un poche
en sifflant le juste pour mieux
s'assurer qu'on ramasse nos canettes
il ya il ya il ya des personnes noires
qui diront que oui
bien des personnes noires qui donc voir
une police c'est source de beaucoup
d'anxiété mais c'est juste que je pense
que beaucoup des concepts qui sont
réfléchies
c'est mettons justement tu y mettons le
slogan défendre de police pissos etc des
concepts qui nous viennent qui ont été
réfléchis aux états unis selon leur
contexte puis qu'on importe puisque on
scande sans vraiment se poser la
question c est ce qui est ici dans notre
contexte québécois ça fonctionne c'est
puis petit même ddm des vosges par mail
je parlais à thé avec des gens pitié
m'expliquer anguilles mais comment les
écoles sont fondés par rapport aux
quartiers qui que ça pittis et je sais
exactement de quelles vidéos youtube
il fait référence puis lesquelles ils
écoutent et pixi le cem
américains et donc été très m'expliquer
qu'il est si ça fonctionne c'est manière
différente puisqu'elle en est d'autres
bois qui venu ici je poserai quelle
santé mais qu'est ce que tu penses du
slogan des fonds de police que je pense
que qu'on peut l'appliquer si le cpie
bas c'est clair mat et je prends mon cas
là il ya des problèmes dans la police le
sait sur pied en béton et or c'est
justement tout comme on est en tout cas
une étude qui dit oui mais qui dit
qu'ils étaient à montréal 2 6 fois plus
de chances de faire profil east and west
érable c'est quand même non négligeable
t mais après ça il dit le contexte
américain ça est ce que c'est une police
qui eut le 3000 tabriz et le pion de
l'armement à ne plus finir le tir parce
que parce qu'ils ont acheté saab est
justement de l'armée pis c'est une
police qui est vraiment plus à un
problème justement systémique de
brutalité policière puis d'inégalités
raciale plus sollicités mais après ce
clairement il ya des améliorations à
faire ici il est injuste estimons le
vide un média aussi eu des des ddh les
personnages autochtone abattu par la
police il est utile d or il y en a aussi
un sûr bien sûr mais est-ce qu'on peut
appliquer chacune des réalités où chacun
de ses slogans les autres marchés parce
que dans certains contextes sont très
valide mais après ce nouveau ton si je
pense que beaucoup des hashtags de
basware comme ce con con ce cadre un
petit plus à réfléchir vraiment à notre
réalité c'est ça ça c'est le danger de
d'avoir une puissance une puissance
économique qui en plus d'être une
puissance économique est une puissance
culturelle
j'ai toujours été fasciné par le fait
que moi quand j'étais gamin en afrique
dont l'afrique a été colonisée
colonisation mais je pense quand même
que sinon si on doit fermer une fenêtre
de l'histoire puisse être over
simplifiée mais
si on doit prendre une période de
l'histoire 1 entre le xviie siècle et là
les années 60 qui ont les années où la
plupart des pays africains ont eu leur
indépendance et qu'on la compare même
période
donc si on compare cette période là le
sort des africains sur leur continent
pendant cette période au sort des afro
américains aux états unis pendant cette
même période
psychologiquement
l'afrique a un avantage parce que ce que
la l'esclavagé a fait à la population
afro-américaine à des conséquences
psychologiques a eu des conséquences
psychologiques sur ce groupe là qu'on
arrivera peut-être un jour à a nommé
pierre est pas rien comprendre et à
préparer je ne sais pas peut-être je
l'espère mais ces immenses immense
jamais compris pourquoi quand j'étais
gamin moi avec mes amis pour nous la
personne noire par excellence qui avait
super supériorité en tout supériorité de
goût supériorité en culture voire
intellectuelle en tout cas
définitivement supérioté général était
le noir d'amérique avant d'engager un
africain pour des enfants pour des
enfants africains un descendant
d'esclave était notre modèle il ya
quelque chose dans l'exportation
culturel et dans l'hégémonie culturelle
des états unis si je pense a pas fait
beaucoup de bien à la population noire
du reste du monde parce que on a tous
fini par s'identifier à cette
psychologie poste etc cela va juste
c'est sexy c'est tellement insidieux son
jeu s'est même pas on sait même pas
comment ça se passe juste qu'on se
réveille ticket
je pense que j'espère j'espère que ça
change un petit peu mais il ya toujours
eu des mouvements panafricanistes puis
j'espère qu'ils vont ils vont se
renforcer de plus en plus pour donner
une souveraineté mental a à mon
continent mais j'ai jamais compris
pourquoi on s'était toujours identifiés
aux afro-américains et qu'on s'en était
servi comme modèle ce que ça fait c'est
que quand on était petits des fois on
regarde ministre socialiste boyz'n the
hood
puis on trouvait ça doit me trouve ça
cool et si on en avait si on si on avait
été si on avait vécu dans un pays où
assez paradoxalement qui n'était pas une
dictature
ouais donc où on se sentait le droit de
faire ce qu'on veut quand elle voulait s
révélé exprimé s'exprime par les codes
culturels qu'on apportait un petit peu
partout dans le monde on aurait fini par
traduire ce glamour de 2,2 des ghettos
américains dans notre quotidien
ce qui n'aurait rien apporté de bon à
notre société sait on se rendait pas
compte qu'ils avaient absolument rien
que la mule dans le dans l'amérique des
dépôts hajek ce poste le le le
c'est au riz puisque ce qui ce qu'ils
ont fait ou à certains quartiers aux
états unis avec avec avec avec les avec
l'héroïne laisser y aller
une façon délibérée de délibéré ou pas
on n'en sait rien en tout cas un
prolongement claire et nette de deux de
ses gardes et la population noire dans
un certain esclavage et l'expression
artistique de sa qui passait par ses
films de john fingleton ou d'autres qui
étaient en fait des critiques virulentes
de ce système était exportée dans une
avec une manière de faire croire au
reste de la population noire
la jeunesse noire autour du monde que
c'était cool c'était cool des tang ne
puisse aller dans la musique qu'on
écoute n'est pas pour le décor est ce
que c'est parce qu'il y avait pour la
soca contexte pour ses modèles à même ta
propre société
est ce qui se passe qu'est ce que la
raison pour laquelle les modèles
afro-américains qui quel que les modèles
transcender jusqu'à en afrique est ce
que c'était parce qu'il y avait un
manque de modèles ou c'était juste par
désir de sa pote s'approprier mais de de
s'exposer à cette culture le c'était une
façon de en l'occurrence testé à l'oeil
on n'était pas des enfants des
descendants d'esclaves dont et aider des
enfants de coloniser et c'était une
façon d'être des occidentaux tout en
restant noir parce que au delà du fait
que le blanc ça c'est la blessure de
l'afrique c'est que la colonisation nous
a laissé une mentalité de penser que le
les européens et nord américains
savaient mieux faire que nous et
tout l'expliqué aussi dans le podcast
avec mathieu mathieu côté était que
l'adjectif blanc voulait dire bravo
quand j'étais petit est l'adjectif blanc
mon goût c'était un adjectif qui disais
que tu étais at-on affaire these donc on
sait très fort ça finit vraiment par te
par te construire psychologiquement
est ce que les états unis ont exporté
culturellement c'était l'occident
c'était pas le fait d'être noir c'était
l'occident et dans cet occident là qu'on
importait culturellement il y avait en
plus des gens qui nous ressemblent et
avec des codes culturels propres à eux
donc c'est cela qu'il fallait adopter
pour être des noirs supérieur et cc
c'est bien quand on a une certaine
valeur
je pas éducative qui concerne aux élèves
mais quand ça nous fait croire que jouer
au games the way c'est appartenir à
quelque chose de fort alors que ces
films là je voulais quand même critique
par rapport au oui clairement clairement
mais t'as pas de recul quand tu es en
afrique 13 ans 14 ans [ __ ] t'as pas
nécessairement parce que si tu ne vis
pas dans ce contexte là historique parce
qu'une question de l'histoire aussi
c'est ce que ton père et son père avant
lui a transmis comme blessures
psychologiques
quand t'as pas grandi là dedans tu as
grandi en afrique est une autre réalité
où tu as grandi qu'avec au québec ou
même dans dans le xviiie à paris
le c'est pas ta réalité donc tu ne peux
pas avoir le recul même même pour les
jeter des américains qui vivent encore
dans les points ject ils ont pas ce
recul là ça reste ça reste pas parle pas
par la musique c'est comme l'industrie
du pape est devenue ce qu'elle est
devenue parce que
elle a vendu 7 devenu justement une
industrie elle est devenue une industrie
pl a trouvé ce filon là elle trouvé ce
filon la de vendre ses fictions à eau à
la banlieue blanche
si elle a consommé comme une vraie
fiction parce que c'était pas la réalité
et occupe le capital s'est multipliée
puis ça ça ça fait des petits puis c'est
devenu ça mais à la base c'est ça c'est
que c'est partir d'une réalité qu'on
dénonce et qui finalement est récupérée
pour faire de l'argent mais c'est tout
ça qui nous a été exportée et nous en
afrique mais je pense que c'est le cas
aussi pour une certaine jeunesse noire
au québec et je pense qu'à un moment
donné faut faut mettre une certaine
frontières et dire pensons avec notre
lieu c'est pensons avec notre lieu qui
agissons selon qui nous sommes dans
l'âge dans la géographie qui est la
nôtre et importer tout ce qui se passe
aux etats unis
ça peut devenir dangereux parce que
justement ça ça pollue lé discours ça
pollue dialogue parce que j'ai vu que
justement suite suite avec tout de suite
le débat est devenu ouais mais est-ce
qu'on est mieux ou moins bon que les
états unis c'est pas vraiment une
question complètement stérile c'est pas
ça le bull laisser les états unis à côté
étudiants les cas spécifiques au québec
est-ce qu'on peut piller la question est
ce qu'on peut faire mieux ce qu'un
problème ici la réponse est clairement
oui clairement concentrons-nous là
dessus et puis de dire c'est moi c'est
pire aux états unis ça fait pas avancer
la cause
non ces brusques françois legault qu'on
le disait leur a si bien pas vrai
systémique ici quelque part c'est une
façon de dire regardez dans le sud ce
qui se passe le vrai racisme systémique
mais là c'est pas ça c'est pas une
question de
il ya des degrés mais c'est pas parce
qu'un degré moindre ou pas plus que ça
efface la faute c'est les affaires c'est
mais ça change la solution par exemple
où ça change la piste de solution j'ai
l'impression qu'on regarde mais dont on
comprend 2 degré de racisme systémique
mais donc non consentant qui en a au
québec qui annonce de tourner à deux
degrés différents aux etats unis
dans toute l'histoire de défendre police
pour garder cet exemple la solution et
et monétaires s'est fait enlever de
l'argent la clôture hier pardon puis
investissons le dans des ressources puis
comme notre métier méthode c'est de
retirer de l'argent sur une solution qui
la première action et monétaires puis
tandis qu'ici on réalise que la première
action est beaucoup plus dans
l'éducation dans la division des tâches
de la police donc qu'est-ce qui est la
police de récup et qu'est ce que les
travailleurs sociale devrait s'occuper
tout ça c'était la solution est
différente parce que le degré différent
donc donc de savoir que maintenant de
reconnaître que ici maintenant le
problème est moins et un degré différent
qu aux etats unis c'est aussi être
capable de trouver une meilleure piste
de solution que d'implanter la solution
américaine planer site
ouais c'est sûr que c'est chou qui parce
que dès qu'on compare je pense qu on on
se complique la tâche soit exact c'est
sûr je pense qu'il est important c'est
de de reconnaître le problème est de le
reconnaître comme tel mais de se dire
qu'à partir du moment où on l'a reconnu
bastian de faire quelque chose pour
régler le problème et d'adapter le
langage à ça aussi la dap d'adapter
notre notre façon de de parler lorsqu'on
essaie de régler ces problèmes là qui ne
soit pas plein d'emprunt de ce qui se
fait ailleurs
il ya ça aussi la langue est très
importante le langage lexique les mots
qu'on utilise le le le le vocabulaire et
ça c'est dans ses dents tout parce que
si on commence à utiliser le même terme
qu'utilisent les américains
implicitement on compare implicitement
forcément on ouvre la porte vers cette
comparaison là et ça ça dit lui le
propos et ifs
il faut faut se dire oui est-ce que les
problèmes en la police au québec
oui quelles sont ces promesses n'ont pas
leurs spécificités par rapport aux
problèmes aux états unis mais qu'elles
sont le kéké qu'est ce qui se passe
quand on parle de profilage de québec
qu'est ce qui se passe réellement et
s'adresser à ce problème
ce qui est difficile parce qu'on vit
dans un monde de coupe de communication
puis tout le monde veut du croire depuis
tout le monde si tu penses tu avoir
beaucoup plus de réactions et
d'attention en y mettant un petit peu de
oui mais regardez ce qui se passe aux
etats unis
tu vas le faire mais c'est pas la bonne
façon mais je le vois dans tout je parle
à des gens qui sont neuropsychologue par
exemple qui est qu'ils veulent et c'est
de repenser l'éducation le système
scolaire et tous à happy comment est-ce
qu'on comment est-ce qu'on adresse le
problème des deux des enfants
neurologiquement atypique
c'est dans un sens comme dans un autre
c'est que comme ben si il font des
études très technique pour partir de là
et bâtir quelque chose qui va être
présenté à la population
mais les textes sont plaints de
deux notions américaine parce que c'est
les grosses universités américaines qui
est qui et qui écrit ses textes à et on
se rend compte que le vocabulaire
s'applique pas la mentalité québécoise
parce qu'il ya des choses que tu peux
dire aux américains mais si tu le dis
aux québécois ils comprennent ça ils ont
tant d'autres choses
7h10 double exceptionnalité par exemple
ce n'est pas pour les enfants qui sont
et qui font de la devance et qui sont
aidées h tu viens de dire qu'ils sont
deux fois exceptionnel puis que pour le
québécois bas ben ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire qu'ils sont deux fois meilleur
ou deux mois qu'est ce que ça veut dire
exactement
non faut que tu dois comme réorienter
temps en temps ton lexique ton langage
et donc il faut que tu te faut que tu
penses toutes les solutions par rapport
à temps lieu par rapport à ta culture à
ta mentalité atteint et il faut le faire
davantage je pensais ce qui est ce que
ce qui est paradoxal parce que on l'a vu
avec le co vite si on se rend compte à
quel point le le monde est ouvert
puisque les frontières vous sent presque
plus là et en même temps il faut en
avoir il faut en avoir parce qu'elles
sont là parce que je ne je ne suis pas
chien québécois aujourd'hui mais je suis
aussi rwandais mais j'ai aussi des
affinités avec la france parce que ma
carrière et est essentiellement là mais
je suis québécois je vis ici c'est un
c'est une autre façon d'appréhender le
la nation aussi il faut avoir cette
souplesse d'esprit aussi le seul puisse
dire ok c'est ça le québec c'est ça mais
ça reste quelque chose de spécifique
même si c'est fait de plein de choses
bizarres qui viennent d'ailleurs ça
reste quand même un groupe spécifique
qui n'est pas le reste du canada ne sont
pas les états unis mais par exemple si
je peux apporter une nuance à sotchi
mettons techique tuer s'ils ne veulent
pas caste ici chez cailler sur le team 6
pi 6 lui très bon pour mettre les choses
dans leur contexte
excellent pour sa pitié après ceux ci
mais tant pis assure le podcast
amastaibou côté ia vous aviez les débats
sur escaut
est-ce que l'esclavagisme et donc le
racisme et fondateur mais tronquée
d'actifs dans les questions que vous
posez petit même si on va dire ici
évidemment lui beaucoup moins il y en a
eu mais beaucoup moins d' esclavage au
québec qu'aux etats-unis 0-2 unis c'est
vraiment le constituent deux pistes
littéralement construit ou là dessus par
contre à webster explique c'est que rien
qui existent en vase clos t après ceux
au québec on faisait quand même du
commerce avec les états unis avec les
antilles on envoyait no no no no no
pêche de mauvaise qualité pour nourrir
les esclaves dans les antilles et puis
on fait du commerce pis donc tout
l'occident qui les leur passif damas
parce que tout ça était pour renflouer
les coffres des pays de colonisateurs
puis après ce donc
si aujourd'hui l'occident
c'est comme un petit peu mais c'est en
fait s'est enrichie cccc tel vélo j'aime
pas le terme le métier c'est
culturellement pitel et
technologiquement puis économiquement
c'est grâce à l' esclavage puissent
grâce au racisme dans le fonds atypiques
même si on n'a pas commis la faute
directement
je pense quand même que on peut cette
importance rapplique connu profit d'une
certaine manière
ben je vais je aller plus loin c'est que
pour revenir aux privilèges lente montre
ce que j'essaie de dire c'était
peut-être pas très clair mais le les
deux peuvent exister c'est à dire le
privilège blanc comme théorie et le
manque de compréhension de ce privilège
par la vie que l'on mène quand une
personne blanche ces deux choses là
peuvent coexister mais je veux aller
plus loin que ce que ce que tu as à dire
que à quoi puisque défendez il existe
une telle chose et j'ai une chose qui
existe qui et quand une personne blanche
un homme blanc s'y coller le dos contre
le mur et que il te reste plus rien face
à une personne qui est noir ou arabe ou
là
sinon il y a
il peut y avoir un dernier edge qui est
celui de dire j'appartiens à la famille
ethnique
on va dire au groupe ethnique supérieurs
dans le sens où depuis j'ai des
histoires de des parties de l'histoire
qui sont occultés par l'histoire
classique on enseigne à l'école mais
dans toutes les histoires si on doit
penser en termes raciale dans l'histoire
que nous connaissons tous la puissance a
toujours été représentée par un homme
blanc aussi loin que tu veux aller tu
dois aller au temps des grecs jusqu'à
dieu barbe blanche et les yeux bleus les
matches que nous avons de la puissance
est toujours symbolisé par pour revenir
à la force des symboles toujours
symbolisé par un homme blanc qui citait
pas bhl à l anarchie parce que tu es a
par exemple jésus était probalement tepa
blanc comme kodak team qui n'est
clairement pas mais pour dire que dans
l'imaginaire collectif d'une grande
partie de la population la puissance est
symbolisée par sa est la traduction
factuel pratique dans l'économie dans
dans une certaine puissance militaire
dans une certaine puissance même donc
forcément si l'économique masse a permis
à vendre une certaine supériorité morale
philosophique aussi de les lumières en
france et tout ça elle est assise c'est
vrai sur l' esclavage par la force des
choses parce que je parle je parle et
d'hégémonie culturelle tout à l'heure le
monde entier a abandonné ses rêves et
américains et ça a été possible parce
que c'est une puissance qui a réussi à
exporter cette culture et cette
puissance est assise sur l'esclavagé
donc là dessus je veux dire
edge qu'on peut essayer de trouver quand
une personne blanche pour se rassurer
sur sa supériorité en se disant je suis
blanc rouge appartient au groupe de la
puissance ce privilège là il est assis
sur un crime qui l esclavage et un autre
crime qui l expropriation des examens
des premières nations dont on ne parle
pas assez à mon goût mais puis le
sillage de l'arn est exactement c'est
aussi de dire que l'esclavagisme petit
intrinsèquement liée au racisme et au
fondateur au québec c'est complètement
exclu la conversation la question
autochtone parce que justement y sont
arrivés ici en disant ce territoire est
vierge nous appartient si que c'est
qu'on considère les gens qui vivent même
pas comme des humains etc donc si fondée
sur le racisme
absolument je l'a alors la difficulté du
québécois francophones c'est que il a
hérité de quelque chose qui s'apparente
à ce que les noirs ont invité partout
dans le monde je dis bien qui
s'apparente c'est pas la même chose
mais cette idée de détroit d'être en
dessous de l'autre
cette sensation d'être en dessous de
quelqu'un d'autre et d'avoir en commun
avec les autres du même groupe inférieur
des liens culturels très forts dont la
langue le l'idée que et ça c'est quelque
chose que je découvre de plus en plus
quand tu penses à l'aloha à la fondation
du canada le 1 les liens que les
québécois francophones ont pu entretenir
avec les premières nations
versus les liens que les anglais ont
entretenu avec les autochtones
tu commences à te rends compte à quel
point
finalement le set support ici
cette supériorité quitté octroyé par le
fait que tu es blanc n'est pas forcément
ressentie à travers l'histoire par le
québécois francophones la même façon que
le reste des canadiens anglophones c'est
à dire c'est cette sensation tu es au
top de l'échelle raciale le québécois
francophones a pas tant a hérité ça
parce qu'il a toujours été un petit peu
le soumis le soumit de l'autre et ça
c'est vrai aussi quelque chose dont je
commence à m'en rendre compte
et c'est là que je me dis ben c'est vrai
que je te regarde le canada anglophone
regarde la télé anglophone ya beaucoup
plus de diversité puis salaires ou les
grandes villes anglophones ont l'air
plus que peut pas les pas les grands pas
les grandes villes mais en tout cas
quelque chose dans le dans la culture
médiatisé et industrialisé qui donne
l'impression qu'on est beaucoup plus
ouvert d'esprit du côté anglo que du
côté québécois
puis je me suis barbe ça vient d'où ben
je commence à penser à moi d'où vient
mon pays pire c'est difficile d'être
ouverts d'esprit quand t'as pas
l'impression que tu as ta place qu'on
prince et c'est sa sas applaudi pas là
c'est comme non les essayent parce que
c'est à ton avantage de t'ouvrir mais je
comprends que soit difficile mais c'est
qu'il faut qu'on branche penser qu'on
peut à être repris mais et pascal
moureaud primes prime aux primes en
hausse
souvent les pires opprimant oppresseurs
soit présenté à eau est absolument pipi
si ce petit jeu c'est pas parce que sous
prétexte qu on y connecter justement
opprimés par
par la conquête puis par les anglophones
que l'on peut se permettre de commettre
les mêmes fautes après le team alors
bien sûr que non bien sûr d'apprendre
puis deux mais ça n'a pas respecté les
pattes je pense que c'est ça qui manque
dans le discours ambiant que j'entends
c'est d'expliquer mettons québécois
francophones qu'il est dans leur intérêt
de s'ouvrir
puis je parle aux québécois qui qui
serait résistant à l'idée de deux
d'ouvrir leurs portes à ce qui vient
d'ailleurs ce qui je soupçonne qu'ils
sont pas tant que ça honnêtement là j'ai
l'impression écoute pour avoir fait des
tournées en région partout
amy très rarement arrivé de rencontrer
quelqu'un tellement obtus que je sentais
que la personne me rejeter parce que
j'étais noir c'est arrivé mais j'ai plus
souvent en compte je parle en région
j'ai pu se rencontrer des gens qui
étaient curieux devant la curiosité
s'exprime maladroitement way puis en
tant que personne racisées on a le droit
d'être usé est susceptible aussi parce
que défend long le vois tellement le vit
tellement de fois que notre quota de
patience
est atteint ouais mais la curiosité
c'est des fois elle l'était la fameuse
question mais tu viens d'où selon de
quel pied tu t'es levé le matin ça peut
être irritant comme ça peut être drôle c
mais moi je pose la question je parle à
un blanc qui a un accent je vis tu viens
d'où je parle un noir qui a pas un
accent haïtiens à montréal je veux
savoir de quel pays d'afrique qui vient
c'est c'est donc donc il ya tout simple
c'est pour ça que ça faut faire
attention de de jeter la pierre
raciste à tout bout de champ mais mais
je pense qu'il est dans l'intérêt de du
québécois francophones qui seraient
réticents à l'idée d'être plus ouverts à
ceux et à ce qui vient d'ailleurs que
finalement c'est danser dans l'intérêt
de tous
- parce que c'est là qu'on s'en va qu'on
le veuille ton combat d'affirmations
d'état culture la langue française et
versus l'intégration nouveaux arrivants
c'est pas quelque chose qui va au clash
l'équivalent qu'on ne sait non peu puis
en écoutant en écoutant le parc à saint
mathieu bock-côté justement là j'ai
l'impression qu'il ya une chose
la chose principale qui m'est sorti de
ce c'est que j'ai l'impression qu'il ya
une espèce de fausse et de perception
entre le nouvel arrivant puis le
québécois en guinée de souche même sur
jean paul terme puis je cultive mettez
vos côtés en date d'un podcast presque
mot pour mot ses hôtes à la main mais
peut toujours saisi tu sais ça pipi toi
je pense qu'ils ont dans un contexte
spécifique mans politique possible
il parlait du parti québécois puis du
mouvement souverainiste a pas avoir les
moyens de proposer des choses assez de
choses aux nouveaux arrivants ou aux
gens issus de l'immigration pour complet
ce les suivre mais j'ai l'impression que
tu te disais des fois tic
justement en parlant avec tes amis
immigrants issus de différentes
communautés que justement entre la
perception séquelles pq de parti raciste
pis que les québécois est pas tellement
ouvert à la diversité dit non à côté de
tout temps mathieu qui dit ben non on
est ouvert on vous ouvre la porte on
veut juste que vous rentrez dedans gagne
mais on s'en moque ça pour ça que c'est
la volonté
puis de l'autre côté j'ai besoin que que
c'est que les migrants se dit moi je
veux juste participer à la vie du québec
claude jeu juste être être un québécois
vivent au québec il est impliqué mais je
me sens pas 100% bienvenus faites-les il
ya une espèce de discordance de
perception parce que on dit viens t'en
l'audi belge de revenir mais tu veux pas
que je tenais là tu viens de toucher le
coeur de tous à tout ce qu'on entend
dire je suis allé aux toilettes
toilettes juste à gauche gauche il
gauche gauche
ouais sésame et on parlait de
l'immigration puis quand il parlait de
temps de la main tendue il ya quelque
chose que je fais des conférences sur
l'immigration et j'essaie d'expliquer le
malentendu qui a re quand on parle de
l'immigrant souvent c'est quelque chose
qui me trouve super intéressant tout le
monde parle de l'immigrant souffler me
rends je pas si vous avez remarqué mais
les accueillant parle de l'immigrant les
gens qui sont issus de l'immigration
deuxième troisième génération parle de
d'immigrants mais n'ont pas vécu
l'expérience de l'immigrant tout le
monde parle de l'immigrant sauf
l'immigrant c'est rarement les migrants
qui lui même partage l'expérience de ce
que c'est que d'être un immigrant
pilleurs j'imagine que je touche à la
fois été ou non mais je peux je parlais
des personnalités publiques
or c'est les personnalités qui comptent
qui s'expriment pays dont on relais les
robertins des personnalités publiques
qui sont immigrantes bail à bouilhonnac
il y en a quelques déjà y en a pas
beaucoup qui sont issus de l'immigration
mais ceux qui le sont ne sont soit
adopté ce soit deuxième génération donc
ils sont nés ici c'est disons pas
véhicule
la vraie expérience de personnes qui
arrivent ici déjà adulte puis qui doit
s'adapter pire puisque j'essaie
d'expliquer j'ai dit ça un peu de moi à
mathieu en ne disant pas ce qu'il a dit
je trouve que les québécois demandent
pas grand chose mais jeudi mme
l'immigrant demande vraiment pas grave
l'état d'esprit de l'immigrant je pense
qu'il ya pas plus en majorité en tous
cas il n'y a pas un voyageur plus plus
bienveillants qu'un immigrant plus
ouverts et réceptifs et plus ouvert et
réceptif qu'un immigrant temps c'est des
petites quêtes à vie pour venir ici
c'est ça c'est comme ceux venus parce
que les gens parce que souvent quand on
vient comme migrants on arrive dans un
pays où les gens qui nous accueillent
n'ont jamais eu à penser ne fût ce
qu'une seconde ce que ça prendrait pour
quitter son pays
il n'y a rien de plus difficile je pense
dans la vie d'une personne que de
quitter son lieu d'habitat son lieu de
naissance sa culture sa vie y a rien de
plus difficile pour les gens qui
s'imaginent que à un immigrant
finalement c'est quelqu'un qui a quand
ils voient que il ya pas beaucoup
d'opportunités économiques se dérobe
jouer à lui au québec nous sommes
j'aurai une meilleure job pas comme ça
que ça se passe
si tu laisses tout est donc les raisons
qui te chasse de ton pays doivent être
assez forte
tu en est imprégné et quand tu atterris
à pierre elliott trudeau
tu sais ce que tu laisses derrière mais
tu sais surtout ce que tu espères est ce
que tu es prête à faire pour l'avoir
pour de vrai et c'est ni plus ni moins
qu'une vie décente comme tu disais tu
veux juste vivre et là où les gens
pensent que c'est la position de mathieu
bock-côté beaucoup de gens de tu penses
que lui qui disent mais leur problème
c'est oui mais pourquoi est-ce qu'on
devrait renoncer à nos valeurs pour
accommoder les valeurs des autres de
ceux qui arrivent puis moi ce que je dis
c'est quand migrants a déjà renoncé à
tellement de choses on peut pas te
demander de relancer à plus c'est c'est
c'est trop demander psychologiquement
j'ai déjà assez renoncer mais tu sais
quoi je suis prêt à donner encore plus
si je pense que ça va me permettre de
bien vivre dans ce nouveau pays est
généralement il ya ce que j'appelle la
petite fenêtre des merveilles
d'émerveillement c'est celle que
l'immigrant quand il arrive là il sait
ce qu'il a laissée derrière où elle est
laissée derrière puis c'est un
soulagement c'est comme moi j'y suis
arrivé whaou qui assaillent à si la soif
d'apprendre
puis le besoin d'être acceptée numéro 1
chez tout immigrant fenêtre
d'émerveillement si pendant cette
fenêtre d'émerveillement yatuu reconnaît
des choses dans la culture qui te pousse
dans ses retranchements
parce que tu regarde la télé puis tu te
vois pas parce que tu sors dans la rue
puis
entre regarde bizarrement même et c'est
plutôt je pense c'est plutôt le
je te dirais que c'est plutôt la culture
les médias
si tu te reconnais pas là-dedans pendant
cette fenêtre la fameuse fenêtre
d'émerveillement une fois que cette
fenêtre est fermée et que tu es dans la
vraie vie tu trouves pas jobs pour que
tu subsistent et que tu reconnais un
petit groupe de gens qui te ressemble
qui disait regarde si tu veux continuer
et est mieux d'être avec nous puis parce
que c'est une autre culture c'est autre
chose
regarde regarde la télé ce que tu te
vois ce que tu vois quelque chose qui
ressemble au reste du monde où tu vois
quelque chose de très québécois qui
t'invite pas la nature humaine de la
question c'est que tout ce qu'on dit
depuis les deux podcasts un jardin un
jardin cercle t que tous se retrouvent
dans tout en fait si on parle de
l'indépendance du québec par aller
chercher tout le monde sous la même
cause jusqu'à accepter les diversités
les diversités d'opinion la nuance dans
les opinions jusqu'à comment est ce que
on représente les minorités pour que eux
se sentent en arrivant ici comme tu dis
dans la fenêtre d'opportunité qui sans
qu'ils fassent partie du québec on deck
tout ce vin genre de serre constant qui
mènerait vers j'imagine de ce qu'on
parle depuis tout à l'heure la société
québécoise comme on l'aimerait tous les
trois le territoire est absolument faux
pas voir l'inclusion com
1 un dogme qu'on essaie d'imposer aux
uns et aux autres
c'est carrément bien que tu peux prouver
intellectuellement quasi
scientifiquement c'est un bien que
d'être inclusif
parce que déjà cette sors de ta propre
torpeur pita propre souffrance de qui
suis-je bien quoi parce que j'appartiens
et tout s'est tu arrives à trouver des
lieux communs avec plein de gens avec
qui tu peux entendre qui a rien de mieux
pour le pur pour l'être humain en
fonction des charges c'est parce que
quand l'inclusion peut pas devenir la
simulation le temps il faut que ce soit
c'est ça c'est ça soit un focus en
échange pour que c'est celle d'un côté
on sent qu'il ya une ouverture puis deux
puis justement d'apprendre à cette
nouvelle culture qui m'accueille mais
aussi faux faux après c'est une autre
comme personne qui accueille à être
comptés à être conscients des
différences m curieuses et curieux de
toi aussi faire un bout de chemin
inverse en leur remettant un petit par
rapport que les questions de la langue
par exemple le train dont la discussion
avec mathew tait je pense que la langue
c'est vraiment la chose principale qui
veut unir un peuple qui suis brisé qui a
fait d'autant qu'il soit brisée kaka
cette communication les brises ici très
dur d'avoir un vivre ensemble qui est
vraiment parce que sinon tu as parlé
c'est difficile par contre un nouvel
arrivant qui arrivent ici dans une
situation se soit économique difficile
qui parlent pas le français il est en
mode subsistant cela fait de lui un ti
d'être dérangé par le fait que cette
personne ne parle pas français
instantanément je dirais faudrait
d'urgence ils s'épient les enfants de
cet immigrant le prix vont apprendre le
français parce qu'il va grandir au
québec qui pillent et il va avoir ses
deux cultures le mais après ce c'est
aussi une question de facilité la
francisation
ce serait scandaleux des classes chez
moi mon ami à qui on joua dans le dragon
effet seulement
c'est que si ces conditions une scène il
est tout seul avec trois groupes qui le
lie pas garde de suivre ses élèves et
des étudiants en fait en francisation ce
thème dans notre propre camp dans une
situation vraiment de presque de survie
le tcc 6,6 et plus on installait des
priorités c'est d'apprendre d'apprendre
une langue c'est quand c'est juste le
traumatisme de l'immigration en faveur
d'une nouvelle culture qui parle même
pas la langue glisse yves m'en veux même
pas imaginer à quel point ça doit être
difficile de tiens donc c'est ce tir
cadré se bouger le titre de gens qui me
conte l'histoire de thé de madame qui
rentre madame blanche d'un certain âge
le t1 peu qui rend dans une pizzeria qui
se répondre en anglais et qui pète une
coche je la comprends la madame je
comprends sa part traumat au sein du cc
trois mots de passe et sa frustration sa
part tant qu'article agrandi qu'elle a
vécu toute sa vie mais c'est une
génération qui parle peut-être un peu
moins anglais aussi plus est de rentrer
dans un commerce au québec puis de se
sentir moins chez soi parce que tu te
fais pas parler dans la langue qui est
la langue officielle
je la comprends ça ça vient la chercher
mais faut aussi qu'elles fassent un bout
de chemin de dire ben je vais peut-être
que la personne devant toi est en
processus d' apprendre le français ou
peut-être que wall avait raison il faut
qu'il ya et puis j'aurais pu lasser de
ce point de vue là je pense que tous les
francophiles québécois doivent quand
même reconnaître que l'anglais a dépassé
de loin le statut de la langue du
colonisateur
l'anglais c'est juste la langue la
langue universelle c'est plate parce que
c'est aussi la langue du colonisateur
mais il se trouve que quand tu es en
afrique
je parle à un ami ou un ami au rwanda
puis moi j'ai grandi dans un rendez dans
un mandat francophone plus ou moins pire
c'est qu'ils te parle juste anglais
n'ont comme tu leur parles je parlais à
100 kg et de puissants qu'ils sont comme
pourrait le rite de données hors coût de
2 et les rues d'atlanta c'est c'est ça
aussi c'est faux je pense que pour pour
les québécois qui sentent leur club leur
québec a envahi il faut comprendre que
faire cette séparation des choses là il
ya l'anglais la langue du colonisateur
avec tout ce qui est là comme l'eau de
trauma pillée et il ya juste que
l'anglais est dans les faits dans le
monde
donc la personne qui vient d'arriver qui
vient de syrie il ya de fortes chances
qu'elle est juste vu plus de netflix en
anglais avant d'arriver puisqu'elle a
attrapé un peu quelques mots en anglais
avant de reprendre un mot en français
c'est justin le contre argument est
aussi de dire justement est en est que
la langue du colonisateur est aussi la
langue universelle la langue mondiale
faut faire deux fois plus attention pour
pas perdre là le français sans punir
celui qui parle la langue dans ce lot si
c'est ça la news est ce que tu peux pas
reprocher à quelqu'un qui parle anglais
l'anglais qui la langue mondiale
le fait de parler cette langue là tout
en l'associant implicitement des crimes
du passé c'est un petit peu la même
chose que le que l' esclavage et tout ça
c'est abandonner faut que comme société
on se dise nous reconnaissons ce que
nous on s'est trompé ou ont subi mais
nous sommes nous nous sommes notre
propre génération
moi je suis africain mais je ne suis pas
un colonisé ouais je dire moi pas moi
perdre peut nécessairement mais comme
les jeunes africains en afrique
aujourd'hui ils doivent avoir cette
mentalité plus rien qu'on peut faire
c'est ça un blanc qui est qui et dans le
tennessee doit pouvoir dire je suis
blanc américain mais j'ai
j'ai lâché personnes ok ce comme un
partant de ce principe n'est pas une
ferme de coton c'est ça je suis noir de
dents lui ce concert ouvert mon je suis
pas mais je suis pas un esclave je ne le
suis pas mes ancêtres n'ont ainsi mises
en scène ont été ça nous a fait du mal
mais je ne le suis plus et essayant
d'entretenir des relations basées sur
cette nouvelle identité trouvé c'est
comme partant de le part ton pardon de
la tension nous défaire de deux de ses
prisons psychologique du passé c'est pas
une chose facile mais au moins sans
parler puisse dire garde
j'arrête d'être regardé comme si c était
le petit fils et arrière petit fils d'un
esclavagisme et puis tu arrêter de me
regarder comme si j'avais un lien
quelconque avec je suis pas quelqu'un
qui a fait la couverture du journal de
montréal en 95 chef de gang de quel jeu
suis pas quelqu es quelqu'un de rue puis
on va se regarder comme individu
d'aujourd'hui 2021 qui nous sommes on se
rappelle du passé mais le présent et
l'avenir sont peut-être plus important
c'est important de savoir d'où l'on
vient mais cette notion de faut savoir
d'où l'on vient pour avoir en vain il ne
faut pas rester qui on a été lun c'est
ça ça nous aide pas je pense que c'est
la meilleure façon de terminer cette
conversation les merci les gars étaient
vraiment c'est vraiment impressionnant
s'est vraiment passé un très très cool
on invite les gens à écouter ton podcast
y est ce parce qu'ils ont de celui-ci
les gens veulent plus de corps mais à
coup sûr sur mérize obama star juste
chiant c'est drôle parce que je suis pas
très suis pas très réseau mais à force
avec avec le pad casse justement là je
je je je m'y intéresse un peu plus je me
suis plus un consommateur de réseaux
sociaux que je suis un créateur avec le
podcast où commence donc osé ça c'est à
mon podcast il va continuer puis amours
suprêmes amour suprême avec les races à
bonn
merci beaucoup et merci les gars